Wir wollen blicken auf den europäischen Top-Fußball bei den Männern. Wir blicken auf die Champions League, aber natürlich auch auf die Eredivise mit Daniel Zander, auf die Premier League mit Chris McCarthy, auf die Liga A mit Jakob Havke, auf die Serie A mit Christian Bernhardt und auf La Liga mit Nils Kahn. Es ist viel zu besprechen. Legen wir los.
Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Der sechste Name in der Runde ist meiner Max Jakob Ost. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und schön, dass wir hier ja vollzählig erschienen sind, also ihr erschienen seid. Hallo in die Runde. Hallo. Guten Morgen. Merkt ihr das eigentlich, dass ich, wenn wir so viele sind, immer in der Reihenfolge der Bilder, wie ihr bei mir angeordnet seid, gehe, damit ich auch ja keinen vergesse, als eine Urangst von mir, dass ich in diesem Intro, dass ich alle vorstellen und einfach einen vergessen habe. Das wäre ein bisschen argpeilig. Zum Glück noch nie passiert. Was auch nicht passiert ist, ist ein Finaleinzug des FC Bayern. Es hat nicht gereicht gegen PSG, sehr frühes Gegentor. Es geht einfach nicht ohne Gegentor. Und dann hatte man auch nicht so wirklich den Esprit nach vorne. Wenige große Chancen. PSG mit sehr, sehr vielen Spielern im eigenen Strafraum. Und eigentlich hatte PSG dann in der Summe vielleicht sogar die besseren Chancen insgesamt als der FC Bayern. Ich weiß nicht, wer von euch sich bemüßig fühlt. Vielleicht du, Jakob, beginnst mal. Du hast der PSG immer genau im Auge. Was sind deine Gedanken zu diesem Halbfinale und dem erneuten Finaleinzug von Paris?
Es ist im Grunde so ein bisschen gekommen, wie ich es schon im Vorhinein erwartet hatte. Also, dass der entscheidende Unterschied zwischen diesen beiden offensiv ganz ordentlichen Teams ist, dass Paris, glaube ich, ein bisschen besser verteidigen kann. Es war ja im Grunde so ähnlich, wie es auch schon in den Viertelfinals gegen Liverpool beispielsweise war, wo sie auch an der Anfield Road halt lange einfach nur dem Druck standgehalten haben und auch der Stimmung. Und im Grunde hat das jetzt so halt gegen die Bayern ja auch funktioniert. Und ich glaube, das war dann tatsächlich der entscheidende Faktor. Ich hätte mir zum Beispiel nicht vorstellen können, dass die Bayern in der gleichen Ausgangslage ähnlich gut defensiv es geschafft hätten, Quaratzke, Dembélé, Doué und so weiter zu verteidigen. Und das war schon echt beeindruckend. Natürlich dann mit so ein paar herausragenden Spielern. Also ich fand zum Beispiel Pacho hat ein richtig gutes Spiel gemacht. Ich glaube, im Rückblick war vielleicht der Ausfall von Hakimi sogar ein Segen für Paris, weil Saïe Emmery einfach defensiv schon nochmal deutlich besser ist und auch seine Position ein bisschen besser hält. Und so war es dann unterm Strich jetzt abgesehen von etwaigen Schiedsrichter-Kontroversen durchaus ein verdienter Finaleinzug auf jeden Fall.
Aber wie groß sind für euch diese Kontroversen? Weil ihr habt jetzt, ich habe jetzt hier drei nicken sehen bei verdientem Finaleinzug. Ich würde auch dazu nicken, weil insgesamt war Bayern nicht gut genug. Über den möglichen Handstrafstoß müssen wir nicht reden. Das war einfach Regelunkunde im Live-Call des Spiels. Gibt es halt einfach keinen Strafstoß, wenn der eigene Mitspieler dich anschießt. Und der Ball nicht irgendwie Richtung Tor oder so geht, dann gibt es da keinen Strafstoß. Das wissen ja inzwischen alle. Jetzt bleibt halt quasi noch die gelb-rote Karte, die es gegen Nuno Mendes nicht gab. Habt ihr da harte Meinungen zu? Da will sich niemand raustrauen, was?
Also ich fand, also ich habe dann im Nachhinein auch noch Bilder gesehen, wo es dann doch eher so aussieht, als hätte Leimer den Ball sogar mit der Hand gespielt. Ich kann den Ärger nichtsdestotrotz schon verstehen, weil es schon so ein bisschen auf dem Platz gewirkt hat, als hätte der Schiedsrichter das Handspiel zumindest nicht selbst gesehen von Leimer, weil er es ja schon sehr, sehr spät entschieden hat und es dann so ein bisschen wie Sonne, ja, ich mache es mir jetzt ein bisschen gemütlich und gehe der Entscheidung aus dem Weg, ihn runterzuschmeißen. Aber es kann natürlich auch sein, dass der Assistent von der Seite es ihm gesagt hat oder der vierte Offizielle es gesehen hat. Und ja, es ist jetzt halt schon ärgerlich natürlich, aber es ist für mich auf jeden Fall jetzt auch nicht unbedingt der Hauptgrund, dass die Bayern ausgeschieden sind. Ich meine, sie hatten ja auch danach noch 70 Minuten Zeit, ein besseres Spiel zu machen.
Also wenn das heißt, kommt da wahrscheinlich ein Gelb-Rot kaum vorbei, oder?
Ja. Also ich fand trotzdem, dass es wirklich ein, schon ein spielentscheidender Moment war. Eben weil ich PSG insgesamt, wie du auch sagst, kompletter sehe, variabler sehe und insgesamt besser sehe als Bayern. Wenn du dann aber mit zehnmal ein Spielst, macht das schon einen Unterschied, denke ich, gerade in München. Aber mich hat am meisten frustriert, dass ich achtmal die Kopfvollchance für Neves gesehen habe, aber die Leimer-Handspiel-Situation ein halbes Mal gefühlt in der Übertragung. Ich kann mir immer noch nicht ein klares Bild machen. Also hatte aber das Gefühl, dass der Schiedsrichter auch auf die Seitenlinie zeigt. Also ich glaube tatsächlich, dass der Ligenrichter damit gefunkt hat, aber ganz sicher bin ich mir auch nicht.
Ja, also angeblich warst du der vierte offizielle oder der Schiedsrichterassistent. Jetzt ist ja die Frage, also da kann man sich jetzt wahrscheinlich noch Jahre drüber hinweg streiten, wenn man möchte. Hätte es hier gelb-rot sehen müssen, wenn das Pfeif kommt, da eigentlich kaum vorbei, ehrlich gesagt, glaube ich. Und dann kann man natürlich darüber diskutieren, wie hätte Bayern dann gespielt. Was ich aber halt interessant finde, ist in der Leistsituation kann ich total verstehen, dass es so meinungstechnisch so einen Konsens gibt, der vielleicht ein bisschen drüber ist. Also der Schiedsrichter ganz, ganz fürchterlich und es hätte noch einen Handstrafstoß geben müssen. Und jetzt spielen sie schon auf Zeit. Alles wahrscheinlich nicht komplett falsch.
Und die Up-Sides-Entscheidung.
Und die Up-Sides-Entscheidung, das ist eigentlich das allerwildeste. Harry Kane steht in einem 1 gegen 3, wenn sie dieses Up-Sides laufen lassen. Aber es wird danach so getan, als sei er frei durch gewesen vor dem Torhüter. Aber ich kann das total verstehen in der Emotion heraus und natürlich gibt es auch ein Interesse von deutschen Medien, dass ein deutscher Champions League Finalist besteht. Trotzdem frage ich mich, ist denn das bei euren Ländern, ihr seid jetzt alle eingebürgert oder ausgebürgert, ist denn das da auch so, dass man so schlecht verlieren kann? Es ist jetzt ein bisschen hart formuliert, weil es sind natürlich nicht alle Medien gleich usw. Aber es ist schon interessant, dass es dann immer so viel um Schiedsrichter geht und nicht darum, wie wenig sich Bayern herausgespielt hat und auch nicht darum geht, dass Bayern halt einfach kein einziges Mal zu Null gespielt hat in den letzten 15 Monaten. Gefühlt zumindest. Und so weiter und so fort. Ich sehe hier schon ein paar Grinsen. Ich überlasse euch einfach mal das Feld.
Ich würde mal als Real Madrid-Opfer direkt mal loslegen, nach dieser gelben Karte mit Kammerwinger. Und ja, unglücklich war natürlich auch das das Hauptthema. Nicht, dass Real Madrid auch viel zu viele Gegentore kassiert, viel zu wenig Plan nach vorne hat. Und generell vielleicht auch Glück hatte mal in dieser Runde, also der Carreras fast 11 Meter gegen Ulises im Hinspiel usw. Das wird da schnell vergessen in Blättern wie Marca und Ass, von dem ja natürlich ging es primär darum und auch, was man so von Spielern, von Trainern wahrgenommen hat, dass das viel, ja wir wurden sind primär wegen des Schiedsrichters ausgeschieden. Dass es da sehr einseitig ist und man nicht eben auch Fehler bei sich sucht. So ein bisschen, wie es jetzt vielleicht bei den Bayern der Fall ist. Also gibt es schon auch zumal spanische Medienlandschaften ist ja teils noch mal extremer im Sinne von, du hast täglich ja, Marca und Ass kommen täglich raus, genauso die Mundo Deportivo Sport. Also da hast du ja noch mal viel mehr Content, den es eh gibt. Also sie brauchen irgendwo Themen und dann so ein bisschen sich am Schiedsrichter aufregen. Ja, das ist schon eine Leidenschaft in Spanien.
Dann gehe ich gleich als zweiter südländischer Beobachter mit rein. Es ist in Italien schon auch so, dass dann bei großen Spielen, ja, die eigene Mannschaft auch ein bisschen mehr sozusagen vielleicht emotional begleitet wird. Trotzdem, vielleicht jetzt für ein paar Überraschungen habe ich zum, für ein paar Überraschungen habe ich trotzdem das Gefühl, dass es in Italien die letzten Jahre viel, viel ausgewogener geworden ist. Also da wird sehr oft auch wirklich die Leistung des Gegners oder so dann wirklich sehr honoriert. Also zum Beispiel nach der 05-Klatsche von Inter im Finale gegen PSG, da wurde wirklich auch PSG ja, ja, also nicht nur gelobt, sondern auch analysiert, warum die ja diese Stärke da entwickelt haben und so. Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass das in Italien, also das ist in Deutschland, da habe ich primär manchmal den Blick auf die Printmedien in Deutschland, dass das in Deutschland sogar einen Tick schärfer ist als in Italien.
Ich kann sagen, für die Niederlande ist es ein bisschen anders. Gerade in den letzten Jahren fokussiert sich da auch die Berichterstattung auf das Scheitern von Ajax oder PSV. Und da ist es eigentlich nicht so häufig auf die Schiedsrichter gelagert, weil es aber auch in den letzten zwei Jahren keine großen Skandalspiele gab. Aber da ist schon so, dass die Kritik an manchen Stellen noch ein bisschen überzogen ist teilweise. Was aber auch, glaube ich, ins Gesamtbild reinpasst, wenn man in Ajax denkt. In den letzten Jahren waren nach vielen eben nicht erfolgreich. Ich glaube, das führt auch dazu, dass es dann schneller auch eine Kritik dann kommt letztendlich. Aber so ein Schieben auf den Schiedsrichter, wenn ein Team des Landes ausscheidet, war jetzt eigentlich länger nicht mehr da tatsächlich.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe es natürlich auch ein bisschen überspitzt. Machen nicht alle so. Aber ich habe zum Beispiel eine Fotomontage gesehen, wo das Cocorea-Handspiel, natürlich das Cocorea-Handspiel, rausgeholt wurde und als Kopf hatte Cocorea das Logo vom PSG. Und da dachte ich mir, Leute, irgendwann muss man es auch gut sein lassen. Also es war halt nach damaliger Ausregel- legung nicht zu 100 Prozent ein Strafstoß. Hätte er es gepfiffen, wäre es gestanden. Aber es war halt nicht so. Danach haben sie die Regel geändert. So wie mit den gelb-roten Karten übrigens auch. Dann hätte das nächstes Jahr, kann das gecheckt werden. Und da muss man ja sagen, eigentlich scheint das IFAP schon die Punkte zu packen, die halt besonders viel Frust erzeugen. Es hat halt noch nicht funktioniert. Aber Chris, vielleicht willst du noch was sagen?
Ich würde mich eigentlich so ein bisschen bei Nils anschließen. In England ist es schon ein großes Thema, weil in England redet man gerne über Fußball. Man redet gerne viel über Fußball und man regt sich auch gerne auf. Und dann ist natürlich auch die Schiedsrichter-Thematik ganz groß. Und ich habe das Gefühl, auf der Insel ist auch sehr viel Frust, was den Waren geht. Und man hat ja auch quasi durchgerungen, dass man die Aufzeichnungen der Gespräche zwischen den Schiedsrichtern auch veröffentlicht bekommt und so weiter. Also da sieht man schon, da ist Interesse, da ist Druck. Ist immer ein großes Thema, finde ich, nach den Spielen.
Max, ganz kurz genau, sehr guter Punkt von dir, den hatte ich auch im Kopf. Das ist halt wieder mal ein Beispiel dafür, dass dieses WAR-Protokoll in dem Punkt einfach geändert werden muss. Weil wir hatten ja hier auch schon in der Ligatour ähnliche Geschichten eben, aus der Serie A war es ja Inter gegen Juve, diese Bastoni-Kalulu-Nummer. Es gibt halt gerade in KO-Spielen solche Situationen, die wirklich spielentscheidend sein können. Da würde ich mir logischerweise auch schon sehr lange wünschen, dass man sich das Ganze auch potenziell bei Gelberot noch mal in Ruhe anschauen kann. Sehr guter Punkt von dir, das ist glaube ich noch mal ein Plädoyer dafür.
Und es wird ja auch. Und es ist so ein bisschen widersinnig, weil auf der einen Seite nervt viele der Video-Assistenten mich auch oft, ehrlich gesagt. Aber an bestimmten Punkten wird dann trotzdem danach geschrien, dass es noch mehr sein soll. Und es werden ja nicht nur gelbe Karten, sondern es werden in Zukunft ja auch Ecken und Freistöße überprüft werden. Und das wird manchmal ewig dauern, das sage ich euch. Und das wird auch ganz, ganz oft nerven. Und es wird ganz oft nerven und wir werden dann aber quasi nicht die drei Szenen sehen, die unberechtigt zu irgendeinem Tor geführt hätten, weil wir es gar nicht mehr erfahren werden, weil es vorher overruled wird, die Eckballentscheidung. Also das ist genauso wie mit der Handspielregel auch. Ich habe jetzt gestern gelesen in einem Medium, ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen in welchem, weil ich will hier keine Kollegen schälen. Aber da habe ich gelesen, dass die– ja, okay, das ist kein Handstrafstoß, aber das macht es ja noch komplizierter. Und das ist ja falsch. Es macht es ja de facto einfacher, weil es eine ganz eindeutige Regel ist, wenn es vom Mitspieler kommt. Und es jetzt nicht darum geht, dass jemand ein Tor verhindert, sondern in dem Fall ist ja wirklich eindeutig, dabei geht raus aus dem Schlafraum. Dann soll es keinen Handstrafstoß geben. Und das ist ja klar, da kannst du eine Regel nicht formulieren. Genauso wie die Regel ja mit der Vergrößerung der Körperfläche gerade viel fester formuliert ist, viel greifbarer formuliert ist als vorher mit der Absicht, wo wir immer dann noch hier dieses Kriterium und das Kriterium und das Kriterium, Vergrößerung der Körperfläche. Dann hast du halt so Sachen mit dabei wie, wir regen uns über Alphonso Davies im Hinspiel auf, aber er hat die Körperfläche vergrößert und ja, inzwischen ist es halt nicht mehr so, dass wenn der Ball vorher am Körper war, es dann keinen Handstoßstoß gibt. Genau das haben sie geändert, weil sie gesagt haben, er hat es in Kauf genommen durch die Körpergrößenflächenvergrößerung und das ärgert mich manchmal so ein bisschen. Ich verstehe total, dass man sich aufregt und ich finde auch nicht alle Regeln gut und ich bin jetzt auch der Letzte, der jetzt hier irgendwie in die Schlacht ziehen würde und sagen würde, die Handspielregel, die ist wirklich perfekt. Also auf diesem Hügel will ich definitiv nicht sterben. Aber was mich so ein bisschen ärgert ist, dass so getan wird, als wäre es nur schlimmer geworden. De facto ist die Regel aber eigentlich extra greifbarer geworden. Es gibt halt nur noch die Fälle links und rechts von der Regel, die sich ungerecht anfühlen. Aber das wird es leider mit anderen Dingen auch geben. Christo, willst du noch was ergänzen?
Ja, also zunächst einmal, da bin ich 100 Prozent bei dir und man merkt auch einfach oft, dass das Bewusstsein fehlt, für was die Regel ist. Ich muss gestehen, gestern mit dem Klärungsversuch, da war ich mir auch nicht 100 Prozent sicher, weil ich bei Hand einfach auch meine Schwächen habe. Aber ergänzend dazu zu dem Hinspielelfmeter mit, wenn der Ball erst an den Körper geht. Das Frustrierende da ist, dass das in England beispielsweise noch die Regel ist. Und das finde ich dann auch, wie soll ich sagen, ja unglücklich. Also wenn du in England den Ball an den Oberschenkel bekommst und dann an die Hand, dann ist es kein Elfmeter. Also bin wir da relativ sicher, dass das noch so ist. Und wenn es dann in der Champions League anders ist, ist das ja auch maximal unglücklich.
Ja, okay. Das ist auf jeden Fall fair.
Um vielleicht auch schon mal die Brücke langsam zum Atletico-Spiel zu schlagen. Ich glaube, nach den Hinspielen, wir hatten ja da insgesamt fünf Elfmeter, die gefiffen wurden, nur vier blieben dann bestehen, war ja teilweise die Diskussion, muss man denen geben nicht. Ich soll schöne Grüße von Alex ausrichten. Der hatte gar keinen von diesen fünfen gegeben. Sprich, vielleicht gab es auch da die Ansage von der UEFA von oben im Sinne von die Toleranz der Schiedsrichter hinsichtlich zu pfeifen, ein bisschen zu verringern, ein bisschen mehr laufen lassen. Es gab ja auch bei Atletico die eine Situation, Grießmann schubste von hinten, Trossard eigentlich auch zu wenig für mich. Grießmann kriegt dann auch noch einen Tritt auf den Schuh ab, aber davor gab es wohl ein Offensiv-Hall. Auch da wurde ein bisschen was laufen lassen, vielleicht weil sich die UEFA gesagt hat, wir wollen jetzt nicht jedes Spiel 2, 3 Fm dadurch entscheiden lassen, sondern ein bisschen mehr laufen lassen. Dass jetzt der Schiedsrichter in München sehr unglücklich teilweise aussieht und unsouverän aussieht, kommt noch ein Top dazu. Aber vielleicht ist einfach die Toleranzschwelle ein bisschen geringer geworden. Wie gesagt, bei Atletico gab es ja auch ein paar Situationen nach dem Rückspiel.
Ja, guter Punkt. Aber andererseits ist es dann so, da braucht es aber dann eine einheitliche Linie, die auch durchgezogen wird, die auch kommuniziert wird, ehrlich gesagt, finde ich. Denn ansonsten pickst du dir weiter die Szenen raus. Weißt du, mit Bayern-Fans konnte man super über die allerletzte Aktion im Real-Hinspiel sprechen, wo Ulyse von hinten geschubst wurde? Ja, klar, können wir jetzt auch darüber diskutieren, ob es Strafstoß ist. Aber das siehst du ja, wie selektiv das quasi ist. Manchmal sagen wir, ey, das ist doch eindeutig ein Strafstoß, das muss erpfeifen. Und manchmal sagen wir, wir wollen weniger Strafstöße. Und Atletico ist da ja wirklich ein sehr, sehr gutes Beispiel. Also im Hinspiel der erste Strafstoß, der da gegeben wird. Niemals ist es ursächlich fürs Fallen. Er wartet nur auf einen Kontakt. Aber Verteidiger Stethardt auch richtig schlecht, muss man sagen. Stethardt einfach falsch. Beim zweiten gab es einen eindeutigen Kontakt, der eher ursächlich fürs Fallen war. Warum wird er noch zurückgenommen? Aber gut, so ist es. Wollen wir über das Rückspiel sprechen von Arsenal gegen Atletico? Nils, du hast ja quasi schon angesetzt und Chris ergänzt dann sehr gerne.
Ja, bei Atletico war so die Frage, was erwartet man diesmal, weil sie es im Hinspiel gezeigt haben, dass sie es können, dass sie auch nach vorne attraktiv schnell spielen können. Das haben sie an Halbzeit 2 des Hinspiels gezeigt. Deswegen war es die Frage, wie gehen sie es an? Schlussendlich war es eigentlich ein Spiel, das Rückspiel, wo sie ein bisschen wieder mehr Angst davor haben zu verlieren, als den Mut zu haben, zu gewinnen, was zu riskieren. Das war natürlich dann auch durch die Wechsel, dass am Ende nur noch ein Zerlote auf dem Platz war, aber Alvarez, ein Krisenmann, blockt man vorher auch schon vom Platz. Also da hat sowohl vom Personal aus der Mut gefällt, vielleicht bei dem Stimine, als auch von der Herangehensweise. Natürlich verteidigt Arsenal einiges weg, aber so von der Risikobereitschaft, wie viele gehen mit nach vorne, hat mir da ein bisschen was an Power, an Durchschlagskraft bei Atletico gefehlt. Wir reden natürlich auch über ein verdientes Weiterkommen bei Arsenal, die dann natürlich auch nicht mehr so viel machen müssen. Aber ja, so klare Chancen bei Atletico war ein bisschen Mangelware. Auch da hat man sich vielleicht ein bisschen, wie die Bayern, zu sehr an Situationen aufgerieben, aufgeregt. Da gab es auch noch Giuliano Simeone, wurde auch einmal noch von hinten so ein bisschen geschubst oder vielleicht deutlich geschubst. Also vielleicht ist das dann auch aus Teamsicht. Zieht dich das runter, wenn du jetzt zwei, drei Situationen nicht zugunsten für dich gepfiffen bekommen hast. Und so wirkte Atletico auch ein bisschen, einfach nicht so durchschlagskraftig, wie sie es eigentlich schon in dieser Saison aufgezeigt haben. Champions League-Spiele fallen ja durchschnittlich vier, fünf Tore bei Atletico. Aber das sollte da mal wieder nicht sein, liegt auch am Gegner. Aber wie gesagt, ein bisschen ängstlich gewesen.
Da könnte ich ja jetzt nochmal den nächsten Rund los treten, dass man nicht akzeptieren wird, dass Atletico jetzt anders spielt als noch vor ein paar Jahren. Aber lass mich damit nicht anfangen, denn wenigstens Arsenal bleibt ja konstant. Dafür spielt Arsenal immer superlangweilig und sie kassieren immer wenige Tore und sie spielen ganz, ganz schlechten Fußball. Chris, da können wir uns wenigstens alle drauf einigen.
Nein, ich muss auch sagen, das ist so ein Narrativ, was mich derzeit auch so ein bisschen stört, weil klar, Arsenal spielt deutlich pragmatischer dieses Jahr, hat es auch sehr lange, was das angeht, auf die Spitze getrieben. Dazu gehört aber auch, dass wirklich das gesamte Jahr über zwei Drittel der Offensive ausgefallen sind und man sich deswegen auch so ein bisschen angepasst hat. Und ja, gute Trainer, gute Mannschaften finden Wege dann trotzdem zu gewinnen, auch wenn es nicht schön ist. Aber ich finde gerade die zwei Halbfinalspiele jetzt, die waren durchaus sehr ansehnlich. Also im Hinspiel von beiden Mannschaften, erste Halbzeit Arsenal, zweite Atletico und auch jetzt das Rückspiel. Da hat Arsenal in der ersten Halbzeit eine sehr, sehr ordentliche Leistung auch nach vorne gebracht. Im letzten Drittel hat es dann gehakt. Aber wenn wir von ansehnischen oder offensiven Fußball reden, finde ich es immer ein bisschen vermessen, das Ganze nur an der Chancenkreation oder sonst was auszumachen. Es gibt ja auch einen Aufbau. Es gibt ja auch die Spiele im Mittelfeld in Szene zu setzen. Es gibt Dribblings, es gibt starke Pässe vorher. Und da ist Arsenal in den letzten paar Spielen deutlich, da zeigt die Kurve deutlich nach oben. Und ich habe eigentlich kurz vor der Halbzeit gedacht, es könnte 2-0 in die Halbzeit gehen. Einfach vom spielerischen Gefühl, nicht wegen den Chancen selbst. Klar, dass du dann nach dem 1-0 in der zweiten Halbzeit wieder so ein bisschen in den Verwaltungsmodus gehst, das ist zwar nicht schön anzusehen, aber es war tatsächlich für mich auch so ein Zeichen der Reife bei Arsenal, weil du merkst in den letzten Wochen, es ist offensiv besser. Und trotzdem hast du im Spiel auch das Gespür dafür gehabt, dass Atletico, wie Nils schon gesagt hat, nicht so die Durchschlagskraft nach vorne hatte. Und du hast auch gemerkt, die sind hinten wackelig. Und deswegen war es auch an sich die richtige Strategie, Atletico so ein bisschen kommen zu lassen und auf Konter zu gehen. Und war eher reif, das Ganze dann so souverän runterzuspielen. Und ja, zeigt auch, warum Arsenal ein relativ unangenehmer Gegner ist.
Wie viele Gegentore sind es jetzt? 7, glaube ich, insgesamt in allen Champions League-Spielen. 6. Ah, okay. Ich dachte, sie hätten irgendwie... Ah, das ist, glaube ich, die Frage, ob man die Zwischenrunde dazuzählt oder nicht, weil es ein Spiel mehr ist. Weil einmal haben sie ja gegen Leverkusen noch eins kassiert. Genau, also 6 ohne das Leverkusenspiel, 7 mit dem Leverkusenspiel. Aber jetzt stellt halt einfach mal die Gegentore von Bayern und PSG zum Beispiel dagegen. Dann sieht man eben hier einen deutlichen Unterschied. Auch stellt die Gegentore von Atletico dagegen, sieht man einen deutlichen Unterschied, haben wir ja hier auch schon thematisiert. Nur um das einmal kurz einzuordnen, also ich verstehe schon, dass man verschiedene Stile unterschiedlich gut finden kann. Ehrlich gesagt begeistert mich das Rückspiegel jetzt auch nicht. Also ich habe ehrlich gesagt sehr wenig Erinnerungen daran. Aber wenn man sich mal die herausgespielten Großchancen anguckt, jetzt von der Champions-League-Saison insgesamt, ist Bayern auf 1 mit 70, PSG auf 2 mit 59. Also der Unterschied ist schon mal krass, aber muss man auch sagen, gut, da müssen wir dann auch noch mal näher in Play-offs, also K.o.-Runde versus Gruppenphase reingucken. Dann Liverpool und Real. Und dann kommt schon Arsenal, haben genauso viele wie Real mit 55 Großchancen. Atletico 45 auf Rang 8. Also es ist auch wirklich nicht so, dass die beiden mauern würden. Aber eigentlich konnte man das jetzt auch sehen. Aber bedeutet ja Nils, dass Diego Simeone, der ja so unfassbar lange einfach schon bei Atletico ist, diesen einen Titel, dem er so sehr hinterherjagt, er wird ihn wieder nicht gewinnen. Was bedeutet denn diese Niederlage für Atletico? Und was wird das jetzt für eine Saison gewesen sein für Simeone?
Gute Frage. Letztes Jahr gab es ja auch schon große Shoppingtour. Da hatte man ihm vielleicht noch verziehen und den Team verziehen, dass es da noch nicht gleich alles ineinander verwachsen ist. Ich meine, er hat jetzt in den letzten 3, 4 Transferperioden über 400 Millionen Euro ausgegeben. Auch ein bisschen Geld von einer Airline, die noch gar nicht fliegt aus Saudi-Arabien. Also auch alles ein bisschen dubios, aber ja, groß eingekauft auch da wieder.
Moment mal, da muss ich ganz kurz reingehen. Das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Die werden von einer Airline gesponsert, die noch gar keine Airline ist?
Genau. Riyadh Air wurde vor 2, 3 Jahren gegründet, obwohl Saudi-Arabien ja schon eine Staats-Airline hat. Sprich, die haben mal wieder geschaut, wie können wir irgendwie das Sponsoring finden, um irgendwo Geld reinzupumpen. Also das ist so peinlich. Und ja, seitdem, also die generieren noch keine eigenen Umsätze. Die haben jetzt teilweise mal aus irgendeinen London-Flieger gemietet, aber keine eigenen Flugzeuge und fliegen quasi noch nicht selbst. Und deswegen ist das ein sehr dubiöser Deal mal wieder. Atletico hat da schon einige dubiöser Sponsoren gehabt.
Wusstet ihr anderen das alles? Liegt das jetzt an mir? Okay, Gott sei Dank schüttelt Christian, forever best friend, Christian hat auch den Kopf geschüttelt. Das ist ja total abs... Ach Gott, ey Fußball, man muss ihn einfach nur hassen. Gut, reden wir weiter beim Fußball. Aber daher kommt das Geld unter anderem für die vielen Transfers. Und das hat man ihm erst noch verziehen. Aber jetzt, wird es jetzt dann enger für ihn oder was meinst du?
Ja, was heißt enger? Er ist ja trotzdem irgendwo ein Sonnengott bei Atletico. Er kann sich nur selbst entlassen, er hat da volle Gewalten über Transfers, über Entscheidungen des Clubs und so weiter. Von dem her, dass ein Simeone da deswegen jetzt irgendwie gehen müsste oder so. Das ist glaube ich immer noch weit davon entfernt. Wie gesagt, er könnte eher selber jetzt sagen, er hat es jetzt versucht, es ist zum dritten Mal knapp gescheitert nach den Finals 14 und 16. Und diese Saison fühlt es sich schon teilweise so an, dass es nicht nur von einem Grießmann oder auch von einem Koke so letzten Tänze werden, sondern auch von Csolo Simeone. Es gab das Pokalfinale, da sind sie ja schlussendlich auch irgendwo im Elfmeterschießen in entscheidenden Momenten versagt. Fehlschüsse von Alvarez und so weiter. Von dem her ist es mal wieder so, das alte Thema Atletico macht schon teilweise einiges richtig, ist schon in Wettbewerben immer länger dabei. Letztes Jahr ja auch gegen Real Madrid im Champions League erst im Elfmeterschießen ausgeschieden, aber es fehlt halt immer noch so dieser letzte Schritt, dieser Killerinstinkt, was auch immer, der auch jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen Atletico gelehnt hat. Wie gesagt, sie hatten mehr Angst davor zu verlieren, als irgendwie, dass sie Risiken eingegangen sind. Und ja, das trotz eben 400 Millionen Euro auszugeben, auch ein bisschen was verkauft, auch 200 Millionen Euro eingenommen diesen 3, 4 Sommer. Und trotzdem hat der Simeone seit oder in den letzten 10, 11 Saisons nur einen großen Titel gewonnen. Das war die Meisterschaft 2021 und seitdem nicht mal mal, nicht mal eine Copa del Rey gewonnen. Das ist schon eigentlich eine erschreckende Bilanz. Also eigentlich müsste man längst auch mal dann den Simeone hinterfragen, speziell wenn da so dubioses im Hintergrund läuft. Aber wie gesagt, er kann sich da eigentlich nur selbst kündigen und hat man sich alles anders vorgestellt, ein Grießmann sowieso. Aber ja, da hat halt, wie gesagt, mal wieder ein bisschen was gefehlt an Killer Instinkt.
Aber wie würdest du denn das sehen? Also Simeone ist seit 2010, 2011 bei Atletico. Das heißt, er ist jetzt im 16. Jahr, was er einfach irre für sich genommen ist. Er hatte nie eine schlechtere Liga-Platzierung als 5. Und das war auch als 5. Platz. Das war schon im ersten Jahr so. Ansonsten ganz, ganz oft 2., 3., Und dann eben, ja gut, oder hat noch eine Meisterschaft, natürlich 2013, 2014 geholt. Das ist allerdings jetzt schon sehr, sehr lange her. Also zweimal hat er quasi in seiner gesamten Zeit diesen Titel geholt. Wie würdest du es denn sehen? Ist denn überhaupt mehr möglich, so wie die spanische Liga konstruiert ist?
Also mehr ist an sich erstmal möglich, weil Atletico hat schon gezeigt, sie können auch direkt und schnell nach vorne. Es ist nicht mehr nur dieses kämpfende und verwaltende Atletico, das zeigen sie teilweise immer noch und haben auswärts irgendwie ihre Probleme. Aber sie haben auch schon viele Tore dieser Saison erzielt und das nicht nur in Champions-League-Heimspielen, von dem ja, wenn der Trainer erstmal die Mannschaft machen lässt und wie gesagt, Alvarez Grießmann, auch ein Lokmann vorne, Sirloch spielt eigentlich auch eine Weltklasse Saison, dann kommt da schon einiges zusammen. Sprich, du könntest theoretisch schon auch mal einen nazenalen Titel in Angriff nehmen, Real Madrid schwächelt und nach einem zweiten titellosen Jahr in Folge, dann könnte es auch ein drittes titelloses Jahr geben bei Real Madrid. Anderes Thema. Barca ist natürlich offensiv furios, aber hat auch defensiv einige Probleme. Also du könntest auch mal in der Meisterschaft mittreten mit so einem Kader mittlerweile, mit den finanziellen Mitteln. Corpore de Rey sollte nicht sein, aber wie gesagt, so im Fanlager bei Atletico würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass jeder zu Saisonbeginn sagt, Champions League Finale ist auf jeden Fall Pflicht. Logischerweise, man fühlt sich ja trotzdem immer noch als Arbeiterklub, auch wenn man wie gesagt unter den finanziell stärkeren Längste angekommen ist. Aber die Bilanz der letzten 11 Saisons, nur ein großer Titel, ist eigentlich sehr ernüchternd und deswegen nicht. Man vernimmt schon hier und da mal Kritik, das war auch die letzten Jahre, immer mal rund ums Simeone, weil es immer mal viele Patzer gab oder unnötige Patzer, speziell auswärts, wo das Team sich teilweise lustlos präsentiert. Jetzt ist man halt 4. in der Liga, aber das ist okay, weil man ja dafür dann ins Pokalfinale und jetzt im Champions League Halbfinale war. Aber rein theoretisch könnte Atletico schon für mehr bereit sein und mehr mithalten, speziell mit Real Madrid. Teilweise gab es ja auch viele Derby-Siege oder Erfolge die letzten Jahre, aber da geht jetzt ja auch ein Grießmann im Sommer. Das ist natürlich dann ein großer Verlust. Dafür hat man den Alex Baena geholt, der jetzt noch ein erstes, nicht ganz so beragendes Jahr hatte, aber der soll ja dann da die große Rolle übernehmen und mal gucken, was Cholo Simeone da weiter macht, ob er da weiter Lust drauf hat. Wie gesagt, er kann sich nur selbst kündigen, aber auch da an Finanzen mangelsbei nicht. Das heißt, dass er und seine Frau insgesamt 150 Wohnungen besitzen. Also, der ist hauptberuflich fast Vermieter mittlerweile als Fußballtrainer, aber nochmal anderes Thema.
Also, er hat ein bedingungsloses Grundankommen. Sehr schön. Da gratulieren wir ihm doch ganz herzlich zu. Hey Atletico, da könnte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt ewig mit dir darüber reden, weil wenn man ja auch in die Geschichte von Atletico reinguckt, dann ist sie ja auch geprägt von schillernden Charakteren, würde ich jetzt mal formulieren, Präsidenten im Whirlpool und so weiter und so fort. Und eigentlich war ja Simeone schon der, der ist ja quasi der Frank Schmidt von La Liga, 16 Jahre bei einem Verein und der da Stabilität einfach reingebracht hat. Also unter ein gewisses Grundniveau ist Atletico nicht mehr gefallen. Und dann hat sich Atletico wirtschaftlich saniert, neue Stadion und so weiter und so fort. Infrastruktur hat sich alles geändert, Sponsoren, Landschaft, ganz offensichtlich auch, wie wir jetzt erfahren haben. Und jetzt ist dann die Frage, reicht denn das eigentlich? Reicht uns das oder wird das nicht irgendwann dann doch langweilig? Brauchen wir mehr? Naja, wir werden es auf jeden Fall verfolgen, wie es bei Atletico weitergeht. Aber wenn wir schon gerade dabei sind, über Meisterschaftswürdigungen zu sprechen oder eben nicht erreicht der Titel, dann lasst uns doch mal nach Italien blicken. Denn Christian, da hat es jetzt Inter dann doch geschafft, sich den Scudetto zu holen. Jetzt könnten es zwei Titel werden, das Double plus auch bei Inter. Da könnte man jetzt ja lange noch mal über Champions League und so weiter sprechen. Was würdest du denn sagen, war das, was Inter ausgezeichnet hat in dieser Saison?
Ja, viel, würde ich sagen. Also klar, Kapitel Champions League kommen dann auch noch ganz kurz drauf. Das war logisch die große Enttäuschung in der Saison. Aber der Rest war schon grosses Kino. Also was Inter jetzt da in der Liga hingezaubert hat, waren jetzt ja auch drei Spieltage vor Schluss, aber es war eigentlich seit Wochen jetzt auch klar, dass Inter die Mannschaft da vorne ist, die das macht. Vielleicht erst mal so ein paar Statistiken, die vielleicht auch ein bisschen überraschend kommen. In Italien sind jetzt 35 Spieltage gespielt und Inter hat 82 Ligatore geschossen. Das sind im Schnitt 2,4 und das wird in Europa ligaweit nur von Bars und Bayern getoppt. Also selbst PSG hat zum Beispiel in der französischen Liga im Schnitt einen kleinen Tick unter Inter. Also man sieht da schon, unter Kiwo ist da schon, ja, wie soll ich sagen, also ich würde nicht sagen Paradigmenwechsel, denn unter Insagi war das ja schon auch eine sehr fluide Mannschaft, können wir uns alle erinnern, die auch einen sehr ansehnlichen Fußball gespielt hat. Aber Kiwo hat da nochmal was draufgepackt. Auch ein schönes Zitat von ihm jetzt rund um die Meisterschaft. Er hat gemeint, der Fußball hat sich verändert. Man gewinnt jetzt nicht mehr mit der besten defensiven Titel, sondern mit der offensiven und das geht ja schon ein bisschen in die Richtung, dass Kiwo da auch ein bisschen diesen neuen Trend schon auch früh umgesetzt hat. Also wie gesagt, 82 Ligatore in 35 Spielen finde ich schon sehr beeindruckend. Gerade in der Serie A, wo du ja schon oft gegen defensiv gut organisierte Gegner dich sozusagen da durchspielen musst. Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein großes Plus, um vielleicht ein, zwei Namen zu nennen. Man kommt um Fede Di Marco nicht herum in der Saison. Ganz klar, der MVP, Di Marco hat jetzt, glaube ich, 25 Scorer-Punkte. Er hat einen neuen Serie A-Rekord aufgestellt in Vorlagen, hat jetzt, glaube ich, 16 oder 17 Assists. Dazu noch sechs oder sieben Tore. Also Di Marco hat mehr Scorer-Punkte als zum Beispiel Lautaro und alle anderen Top-Stürmer der Liga. Also er hat mehr Tore vorbereitet, als Lautaro erzielt hat. Also Di Marco in der Liga, ganz klar sozusagen das Gesicht dieses, sag ich mal, offensiven Stils. Ja, ansonsten sie haben die Liga dominiert. Also es war ja bis vor ein paar Wochen, vielleicht zwei, drei Monaten, da hatte man manchmal noch so ein bisschen vielleicht von außen die Hoffnung, als ob Milan da dranbleiben könnte. Dann war ja auch dieser Derbysieg Ende Februar, wo sie noch mal reingekommen sind. Aber wenn wir uns auf die lange Sicht anschauen, waren die viel zu unkonstant. Und Inter war die Mannschaft in allen relevanten Offensivstatistik in der Serie A. Also mit Abstand die Eins, also hatten wir schon Tore, herausgespielte Großchancen, Schüsse aufs Tor, also wirklich, ja, total verdienter Meistertitel. Klar, Lautaro wird wieder Torschützenkönig, so ein bisschen das Symbol. Aber haben wir ja auch schon ein, zwei Mal hier gesprochen, schon auch so ein paar neue Elemente, die Kiibo eben gebracht hat. Wir haben uns ja auch diese Saison gefragt, was ändert er vielleicht im Vergleich zu Insagi. Und der hat das sehr clever gemacht. Der hat logisch so die Grundprinzipien dabei behalten, aber er hat halt so nach und nach schon kleine Updates, sag ich mal, mit eingebaut. Also eine viel höhere Kette. Also Inter steht höher, geht früher ins Pressing, geht intensiver ins Pressing und ins Gegenpressing. Das sind es in der Liga auch mit auf 1 oder auf 2, wenn es um hohe Ballgewinne geht. Also da hat er definitiv geschraubt. Ein vertikaleres Spiel. Unter Insagi war noch sehr viel, auch sehr lang, sag ich mal, gezogener Ballbesitz, aus dem heraus dann irgendwas passieren musste. Und Kiibo geht oft sehr schnell vertikal Richtung Stürmer. Also das ist auch eine Anpassung. Und dann, personell logisch, muss man auch zwei, drei hervorheben, so ein bisschen Pio Esposito, der den frischen Wind vorne gebracht hat. Der junge italienische Nationalstürmer. Letztes Jahr war ja bei Inter das große Problem, als sie ja im Mai ja noch überall im Rennen waren, dass eigentlich nur Lautaro und Turam sozusagen offensiv. Also die 1A-Variante war top, aber dahinter kam halt wenig. Mit Taremi, mit Anatovic, mit Correa. Und jetzt in der Saison hattest du halt hinter Lautaro und Turam hattest du Pio Sposito und Bonny, der Franzose, der von Palma kam und die haben halt beide funktioniert. Ich glaube, die haben zusammen auch um die 15 Tore gemacht, haben immer wieder auch Lautaro und Turam Pausen gegeben. Also das hat wunderbar funktioniert. Also auch auf dem Transfermarkt gab es da ein paar gute Einflüsse. Und im Mittelfeld, finde ich, muss man Piotr Celinski nochmal hervorheben, der in der Saison wirklich eine großartige Saison gespielt hat. Er war unter dem Sargi sehr hinten dran, was A dran lag, dass er lange verletzt war und B dran lag, dass dann in Sargi in wichtigen Spielen halt immer mit Ciannolo Barella-Mikitarin gegangen ist. Das war halt einfach sein 3er Mittelfeld. Und in der Saison hat sich Celinski sehr früh etabliert, hat teilweise als zentraler Mann da in dem 5er Mittelfeld gespielt, also auch die Rhythmusgeber, Taktgeber-Roll übernommen. Als Achter auch, hat, glaube ich, nur lieber 6 oder 7 Tore geschossen. Also wirklich, das war der Celinski, den wir noch von früher, von Napoli, gekannt haben. Und hat halt wunderbar deshalb auch reingepasst, weil gerade im Mittelfeld Schalannolo hat immer wieder verletzungsbedingt gefehlt. Also da war viel mehr, ja, viel mehr personelle Breite da. Kiu hat es verstanden, eben nicht nur vielleicht mit 13, 14 Mann zu gehen, sondern wirklich auch das Spektrum zur Weite. Dann so 17, 18, Sučić, der Neue, er hat gut funktioniert. Der hat sich jetzt zum Beispiel mit einem ganz, ganz wichtigen Tor im Koppa-Halbfinal-Rückspiel ins Koppa-Finale geschossen, spät, hat Minuten, viele Minuten bekommen. Akkanji war logischerweise ein großes Upgrade. Der hat Inter hinten, ja, sehr, sehr geholfen, sozusagen, der Zugang von City und ja, also absolut verdiente Meisterschaft. Und ganz spannend, vielleicht schon einen kleinen Blick nach vorne. Ähm, in Italien wird ja immer rundum, wenn dann die Meisterschaft fix ist, werden ja auch ganz viele Interviews mit Präsidenten, mit allem Drum und Dran. Und da wird auch sehr früh schon der Blick nach vorne gerichtet. Und Marotta, also der Präsident, hat jetzt, Marotta hat jetzt als Präsident zum ersten Mal eine Meisterschaft gewonnen in Italien. Italien, glaube ich, ist eine 11. oder 12. Also, kann man sich, liest sich ganz gut, dass, wie sagt man, dass die Erfolgs, oder das Erfolgsbuch, ja, Bilanz von Herrn Marotta. Und er hat schon gemeint, ja, ein so Weg wird sein, junge Italiener, Talentierte zu holen und zu mischen mit erfahrenen Ausländern. Also, Inter hat da schon verstanden, dass sie auch eben diesen, ja, diesen frischen Weg, dass diese Mannschaft logischerweise weiterhin Frische braucht, bei dem, während sie weitergehen, so der eine große Name ist Marco Palestra, der Außenverteidiger von Caliari, den jagt Inter ganz offen hinterher, den jagt halt auch halb Europa. Also, da ist jetzt die Frage, ob sie da die finanziellen Möglichkeiten haben. Aber es ist schon der Plan, da, da jetzt drauf zu packen, um Nexus ja auch in der Champions League wieder eine gute Figur zu machen. Und letzter Punkt, Max, und dann lasse ich dich und die anderen logisch auch rein gerne. Was ganz spannend ist, Inter schließt jetzt die zweite Saison in Folge mit einer positiven Bilanz ab. Also auch wirtschaftlich ist das auf sehr guten Füßen. Finde ich in der Saison noch mal herausragender, weil in der letzten Saison war durch den Champions League Einzug wahnsinnig viel Geld über die Champions League generiert. Ich glaube, Inter hatte letztes Jahr allein durch die Champions League um die 100 Millionen Euro Einnahmen. Also wenn wir über Prämien sprechen, wenn wir über Ticketverkäufe dann sprechen. Und das ist ja dieses Jahr weggebrochen, als sie ja schon in der Zwischenrunde ausgeschieden sind. Plus war letztes Jahr auch noch das Geld vom FIFA World Cup dann im Sommer auch, das ja auch glaube ich um die 30 Millionen waren. Und dass sie trotz dieser, diese Gelder, die sie dieses Jahr nicht generieren konnten, auch aus sportlicher Sicht, dass sie trotzdem eine positive Bilanz am Ende haben, finde ich, zeigt halt schon auch, dass das wirtschaftliche Modal definitiv tragbar ist.
Ich muss zwei Spiele kurz erwähnen. Einmal, Frederico Di Marco hast du ja schon genannt, ist mit weitem Abstand, mit über 45 Flanken, ist er der europäische Topspieler, der die meisten Flanken geschlagen hat. Auf Platz 1, 289 Flanken. Ich habe ein ambivalentes Verhältnis zu ihm, aber sogar ich erkenne, wie gut das in dieser Saison war.
Ganz kurz dazu, Max. Ja, nur sehr viele von den Flanken, von Di Marco kommen halt an. Das ist der Unterschied.
Das weiß ich doch.
Das sieht man am Platz 2.
Da liegt nämlich David Raum. Auf Platz 3 übrigens, Edo Exposito von Espanol, über die werden wir später noch sprechen. Und dann kommt Julian Riazón von Dortmund schon auf Rang 4. Also Bundesliga wieder strong im Flankengame, stark.
Nein, ein Punkt nur dazu, weil ich finde auch, ich glaube vorhin ist ja die Statistik schon mal gefallen. Ich bin großer Fan davon, muss ich sagen, von herausgespielten Großchancen. Weil wir haben sehr oft Vorlagen, leg halt oft, ich kann den perfekten Ball in Fünfereien spielen. Wenn mein Stürmer den dann drüberdonnert, dann stehe ich halt leer da. Aber herausgespielte Großchanzen, finde ich, zeigt schon sehr oft eine Qualität von einem Spieler. Und schaut euch mal liegagreifend, übergreifend an. Da ist die Marco mit riesigem Abstand. Aber wirklich mit riesigem Abstand. Egal, ob du nach Spanien, England, Deutschland schaust. Das ist unfassbar, wie viel gute Bälle der einfach sozusagen die Box reinbringt. Und ja, klar, da wären sicherlich viele Flanken auch dabei, sind die auch nicht immer gut sind. Gar keine Frage. Aber der linke Fuß von die Marco ist schon in der Liga. War er dieses Jahr herausragend.
Absolut. Also ich troll ja nur, weil halt die Statistik so lustig ist. Ich fand's halt lustig, dass da 2 Bundesligaspieler auf Rang 2 und Rang 4 liegen. Das einzige Problem mit den Großchancen ist, dass die Statistikanbieter die unterschiedlich erfassen. Also die Opta-Big Chances unterscheiden sich von anderen. Und das ist dann so ein bisschen so eine Definitionsfrage.
Es ist schwer vergleichbar.
Ja, und deswegen hast du sie nämlich nicht. Also jetzt Großchancen kann ich jetzt gar nicht nennen, weil das ist eine Opta-Statistik. Und bei Opta gibt's, müsste ich mir die Statistiken jetzt pro Liga zusammensuchen und dann eine Gesamttabelle erstellen. Den Rest habe ich gerade von FBref hier abgelesen. Deswegen kann ich dir aber auch sagen, dass Jan Sommer, der Torhüter mit den drittmeisten weißen Westen in Europa ist, in den europäischen Top-Ligen und auf Rang 7 bei den Paraden liegt. Den wollte ich einfach nochmal erwähnen, weil ich kenne niemanden, der Jan Sommer nicht mag. Und dem ist das, glaube ich, einfach wirklich zu gönnen. Ich will jetzt keinen Salz in die Wunden streuen oder Wasser in die Suppe kippen, aber ganz kommen wir ja nicht dran vorbei. Also in der Champions League gegen Bodo Glympt. Ausgeschieden in zwei Niederlagen plus man steht jetzt im Coppa-Finale. Da werden wir ja dann auch später nochmal kurz drüber sprechen. Da musste man allerdings auch erst mal 0-2 gegen Como aufholen. Hat das allerdings auch in beeindruckender Art und Weise getan. Wie bewertest du das beides?
Ja, also klar Pokaleinzug. Nur um das mal historisch einzuordnen, ich muss sagen, ich war selbst überrascht. Es gibt nur einen Hintertrainer in der langen, grossen Historie von Inter, der das Double mit Inter gewonnen hat. Das ist ein gewisser Herr Mourinho, der in der Saison dann auch gleich das Triple gewonnen hat. Also Kivo könnte als zweiter Inter-Trainer überhaupt erst sozusagen auch Meisterschaft-Plus-Pokal gewinnen. Also ja, das zeigt schon, dass das für Inter alles andere als normal ist. Ja, die Champions League schmerzt, da müssen wir gar nicht drum rum. Der Zeitpunkt des Ausscheidens, dann der Gegner des Ausscheidens, ganz klar, das war logisch der große Makel in der Saison. Da gibt es auch kein großes Aber, das nehmen sie logischerweise mit. Aber ja, frag mal Inter-Fans, die waren letztes Jahr im Mai, hatten die überall eine Hand dran und am Ende sind sie leer nach Hause gegangen. Und dieses Jahr feiern sie halt die Meisterschaft, feiern womöglich den Pokal, ist halt immer so eine Sache. Klar hat es ihnen diese Saison auch in die Karten gespielt, dass sie dann so früh aus der Champions League raus waren, hat ihnen logischerweise in der Liga in die Karten gespielt. Ein Punkt dazu, ich glaube, ich habe sie ja auch schon ein, zwei Mal gesagt, ich finde bei Inter, und das war das beste Beispiel dieses Jahr in der Champions League, Inter ist nur dann kompetitiv auf höchstem europäischen Niveau, so wie die Jahre zuvor, wenn alle Stammspieler fit sind. Inter hat nicht die Tiefe der großen Engländer, der Bayern, Real, Barstas. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sehe, bei Bayern fällt Nabry aus, was er erwähnt hat, dann spielt Musiala. Ich weiß, Musiala ist zwar noch nicht bei 100 Prozent, aber nur die Namen, das hat Inter nicht. In der Saison hat Inter monatelang ohne Dumfries gespielt, wirklich nur monatelang auch in dieser Champions League-Phase. Cialanolo war oft verletzt, Lautaro war im Rückspiel z.B. verletzt gegen Bodo. Das kann Inter auf dem Niveau nicht auffangen. Es soll keine Ausrede sein, deswegen solltest du logisch trotzdem gegen Bodo weiterkommen, gar keine Frage. Aber diese langen Champions League-Runs sind bei Inter nur möglich, wenn wirklich alle stammen. Und stamm bleibe ich dabei, wenn Inter scharfgestellt ist mit den Stammleuten, dann können die in Europa mit allen dagegenhalten. Aber wenn das eben nicht der Fall ist, und das war vielleicht auch in der Saison erklärbar, denn Inter hatte letztes Jahr eine Saison mit 63 Saisonspielen am Ende, dann fallen halt irgendwann auch wichtige Leute aus und dann hast du eben nicht die Tiefe mit den ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz großen finanziell schwerkräftigen in Europa.
Aber insgesamt wirklich eine interessante Saison. Und dass sie nur einmal das Double geholt haben, das ist, also das ist wieder so, man nimmt hier immer so Wissensnuggets mit raus, mit denen man einfach sich richtig unbeliebt machen kann im Büro. Weil ich sage, wusste ich dir das denn etwa nicht?
Stimmt, ja. Und der allerletzte Satz, sorry, wirklich nur der letzte, Kivo, muss man schon nochmal, also nur zur Erinnerung, Kivo hat Inter als Trainer im Sommer übernommen mit 13 Profitrainer-Spieler-Erfahrungen. Er hatte 13 Spieler-Erfahrungen bei Parma. Und dann da hinzukommen, wir hatten ja auch schon die Probleme von Inter letztes Jahr im Sommer, da gab es ja doch Erscheinungen, die öffentlichen Kommentare von Giannullo, von Lautaro. Da hat es schon arg gebrannt. Und dass jetzt so ein junger, sage ich mal unerfahrener Trainer, ein Profiniveau, das so souverän zu Ende bringt, in der Liga auch noch die Chance aufs Double hat, ist schon grosses Kino. Also Kivo hat da jetzt definitiv schon in seiner ersten Saison auf einem ganz hohen Niveau schon angekloppt. Mal schauen, wie er dann Inter auch die nächste Saison und die nächsten Jahre weiterentwickeln kann.
Stark, der Sandro Wagner der Serie A. So wird man es doch wahrscheinlich berichten. Ich höre jetzt auch mit meinem Bundesliga vergleichen. Es macht einfach zu viel Spaß. Wir blicken mal in die Niederlande und da Daniel, wird es jetzt anscheinend jetzt ein True Crime Podcast hier. Also ich muss sagen, deine Titelfindung für dein Thema war fantastisch. Entscheidung vor Gericht, 133 Spiele aus dieser Saison müssen nicht wiederholt werden. Das hat auch für Reaktionen bei uns im gemeinsamen Chat gesorgt. Deswegen will ich jetzt wissen, was war da los? Ich habe nichts dazu recherchiert.
Ja, ich muss sagen, das stand im Raum tatsächlich. Also es gab die Rechtsentscheidung aus dieser Woche. Und ich kann ja schon mal so mit nichts, weil er noch nicht. Aber ich sag mal so, es stand im Raum. Und das Ganze hat damit zu tun mit NAC Breda. Das war quasi der Stein des Anstoßes. Das ist ja der Club von Louis Holtby, der da spielt. Und auch von Andrea Ju übrigens, der ist mittlerweile da gelandet. Und trotz der beiden Spieler sind sie auf Platz 17. Und 6 Punkte vor Platz 16 im Relegationsplatz, bei 6 Punkten zu holen. Also der Abstieg steigt eigentlich so gut wie besiegelt. Und die hatten jetzt auch, glaube ich, in den letzten 8 Spielen keinen Sieg. Und hatten echt einen Durchhänger. Und das ist der Grund, warum sie da drin standen. Also zu Beginn der Saison und mitten in der Saison sah es immer ganz gut aus, dass sie vielleicht doch nicht das erhalten können. Aber Wohlennamen und auch Tester haben so ein bisschen Predator überholt. Und jetzt sind sie da, wo sie sind. Und im Abschließkampf klammert sich ja eigentlich an die in Strohhalm, die man so finden kann. Und es ist ihnen aufgefallen, dass sie im März, im 15. März, glaube ich, haben sie gegen die Go-Head Eagles, die Venter verloren 6 zu 0. Das ist auch ziemlich deutlich und eigentlich ohne Chance. Aber die Venter hat einen Spieler eingesetzt namens Dean James. Nicht James Deans, Dean James. Und Dean James ist in den Nähertgeboren, hat aber vergangenes Jahr im März gesagt, ich möchte aber ganz gerne für die derzunehmend auf Indonesien spielen. Und die Nähertlande sind, was doppelte Staatsbürgerschaften mit Nicht-EU-Ländern angeht, relativ streng. Es ist so, dass bis auf ein paar Ausnahmen, ich glaube Geflüchtete oder andere Gründe, die führen dazu, dass man dann auch die Staatsbürgerschaft, die Liga lande, behalten kann oder dort zwei haben kann. Da ist es jetzt aber so gewesen im Fall, wenn man in den Nähertgeboren ist und dann sagt, ich möchte mich da für Indonesien oder für Kuhasau oder für wen noch immer spielen, dann kann man dann rechtlich gesehen die Nähertische Staatsbürgerschaft verlieren. Das ist nicht immer automatisch, aber rechtlich gesehen ist das möglich und angreifbar tatsächlich. Und das führt dazu, dass man dann als Ausländer zählen würde, wo man da geboren ist und dann wiederum, und das ist ja Katus Knaxus, frauche ich eine Arbeitserlaubnis. Und Dean James hat natürlich keine Arbeitserlaubnis, weil er davon ausgegangen ist, ich bin ja eigentlich Niederländer, auch wenn ich jetzt für Indonesien spiele. Und da kann man sich schon die Frage stellen, wie moralisch einwandfrei und integriert das dann ist, mit seinen Anwälten auf diesen Fall zu gehen. Aber ja, in der C-Preda sah darin den Strohhalm, dass man eben da sagt, okay, dann versuchen wir es über diese Schiene und hat dann Einspruch eingelegt gegen diese 6 zu 0. Ich betone 6 zu 0, nicht irgendwie 1 zu 2 mit dem erscheinen Tor von Dean James oder so, nein, 6 zu 0. Und ich wage mal zu behaupten, dass auch ohne diesem Spieler Dean James, dass er ihm nicht ausgegangen wäre. Aber naja gut, Hypothese sag ich mal. Und dann gab es jetzt den Fall, dass erst dieser Einspruch abgelehnt wurde. Und dann kam es jetzt, ging es in die nächste Instanzen, weil er ja wirklich versucht hat, dieses Spiel wiederholen zu lassen und diese 6 zu 0 als ungültig zu literieren und hat dann aber gesagt, wir wollen wieder mal weiterziehen. Und jetzt kam am Montag das Urteil und die haben gesagt, nein, das Spiel wird nicht wiederholt, die 6 zu 0 bleibt bestand. Und vorgestern am Dienstag hat dann Enad Zebrier auch bekannt gegeben, dass sie es gut sein lassen damit und das akzeptieren. Das heißt, dieses Spiel wird dann nicht wiederholt. Und der große Kreis ins Zerspannende ist eigentlich auch die Urteilsbegründung des Gerichts. Denn man hat nicht gesagt, ne ne, der Spieler ist irgendwie, ist arbeitsberechtigt. Ne, also das Gericht hat festgestellt, der Spieler war regelmäßig eingesetzt. Der Spieler sei eigentlich nicht spielberechtigt gewesen. Die Begründung ist, dass man Angst hatte, dass ja, 133 Spiele letztendlich auch wiederholt werden müssten. Denn neben Dean James gibt es noch 20, 25 andere Spieler, die das treffen würde. Und die haben ja alle gespielt in der Saison. Da hätte man natürlich Angst zu sagen, ja, aber was ist denn mit dem von Nijmegen, was ist denn mit dem von Groningen, die haben ja auch gespielt und hätten rein theoretisch alle Vereine, die gegen Vereine verloren hatten, haben mit Spielern, die dann quasi rechtlich gesehen Ausländer sind und eine Arbeitserlaubnis benötigen würden, könnte man dann gegen klagen. Und dann hätte man einen Präsidentsfall geschaffen durch Preda und dann müsste man innerhalb von zwei Wochen an die 133 Spiele wiederholen. Und das Gericht hat festgestellt, dass das ein zu großer Aufwand ist. Und die Belange des Verbands KNVW, die das organisieren müssten, sind dann doch wichtiger einzustufen als das Einzelinteresse von NAC Preda.
Das ist eine interessante Begründung, oder? Also das habe ich bisher ganz selten gehört, dass ein Gericht mal gesagt hätte, boah, den Aufwand, die Strafwärts zu vollziehen, ist schon ganz schön hoch. Also bei Steuerhinterziehung gibt es das noch, da kannst du dich frei kaufen. Politik ist von Reichen für Reiche gemacht. Aber ansonsten habe ich das jetzt noch nicht so oft gehört, dass man gesagt hat, ah ja, komm, lass gut sein. Du bist ja nur schwarz gefahren, du musst nicht in den Knast.
Ja, das finde ich auch eine sehr spannende Begründung. Das heißt auch, für kommende Saison bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass sehr viele Spieler und die Vereine sich um meine Arbeitserlaubnis erbinden.
Ey, da haben ja einige geschmissen.
Was eigentlich auch ein Irrsinn ist. Ja, die hatten auch im Zuge, also die haben ja im Mitte März, kurz nach März, da haben sie also eingelegt. Damals hatte man jetzt eigentlich gedacht, naja, das wird sich ein bisschen verlaufen. Und trotzdem haben dann viele Vereine voraussorglich betreffend Spieler nicht eingesetzt, weil sie da wirklich Schiss hatten, was da rauskommt. Also die hatten das und das auf der Bank, weil ich im Kader und dachte, hm, da müssen wir nicht ganz genau, wenn das jetzt durchgeht. Und jetzt werden sich schnell die Abbezapfere beholt. Was ich aber wirklich, also wie gesagt, es ist halt auch so eine moralische Diskussion, die dahinter steht. Auf der einen Seite habe ich halt als Vereinsverantwortlicher die Verantwortung für den Verein. Und wenn NRC Breda Sportliches nicht schaffen wird, wonach es sehr, sehr stark aussieht, dann guckt man natürlich auch nach irgendwelchen Drehkisten, aber ob man dann wirklich auf das Thema Staatsbürgerschaft gehen muss, ist halt die andere moralische Frage. Ich würde sagen nein, aber es haben sie jetzt zum Glück auch weitere Tote jetzt beruhen lassen nach dem Gerichtsvorteil. Es war ein kollektives Aufatmen sowohl bei 133 Partien, die nicht wiederholt werden müssen, als auch bei den Spielern selbst, wie das betrifft. Das war eine Entscheidung, die doch die Liga ganz gut hätte auf den Kopf stellen können, weil es wäre auch so gewesen, dass dann die Liga vermutlich abgebrochen werden würde und im äußersten Notfall diese Saison annulliert werden würde. Auch das stand dann nicht ganz im Raum, aber es war zumindest eine Option, die so am Firmament aufflimmerte. Was passiert, wenn? Das erinnert sich ein bisschen an die Corona-Saison. Da wurde ja auch das Ende annulliert. Das gab es schon mal. Das wäre nichts Neues gewesen. Das ist natürlich dann der Worst Case. Wie willst du dann entscheiden, wer dann in der Battle League spielt? Wie willst du entscheiden, wer absteigt? Das hätte so große Kreise nach sich gezogen. Aber ja, das heißt natürlich auch, nächste Saison, wenn jetzt ein Spieler im ersten, zweiten, dritten Spieltag spielt, der das nicht gemacht hat, der jetzt auch für Indonesien oder irgendjemand anders spielt, der sich aber nicht um eine Arbeitserlaubnis bemüht hat, obwohl er eigentlich hierher geboren ist, dann werden die Vereine sicherlich sofort dagegen vorgehen, wenn sie verlieren, weil dann ist diese Begründung ja hinfällig. Wenn wir den ersten Spieltag betreten, den dritten Spieltag, da würde ich was finden lassen für eine Partie.
Aber ist denn das aufwendig, eine Arbeitserlaubnis zu bekommen in den Niederlanden? Also es wundert mich auch, dass man quasi Spieler nicht eingesetzt hat, die das auch betroffen hätte und denen nicht eine Arbeitserlaubnis besorgt hätte und die dann wieder eingesetzt hätte.
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen, sag ich mal, wie teilweise in Deutschland die Behörden mühlen, malen auch dort recht langsam. Also es gibt auch relativ hohe Hürden, damit du die bekommst, oder so sind sie nicht. Aber es sind insofern Hürden da. Du brauchst, glaube ich, ein Mindestjahreseinkommen von 600.000 Euro. Das dürfte in der ersten Liga eigentlich kein Problem sein. Aber es gibt schon verschiedene Hürden.
Alle, die eine Arbeitserlaubnis in den Niederlanden brauchen, wollen eine Arbeitserlaubnis mit einer doppelten Staatsbürgerschaft.
Also wenn ich jetzt quasi die niederen Staatsbürger bin und möchte dann mit einem nicht-IU-Land eine doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft haben, dann möchte ich aber mit dieser arbeiten. Dann brauche ich so ein Jahreseinkommen von 600.000. Ich glaube, das gilt dann auch nur für diesen Profisportsektor. Ich glaube, dass man als Privatperson dieses einkommen muss. Insofern gibt es das wenn dann für das Profisportsektor. Und das ist ja für die meisten Eredivisierenden kein Problem. Wobei man sich gerade bei so Aufsteigern, muss man schon mal gucken, ob sie das zeigen können. Aber in der Regel ist das kein Problem. Aber es ist vor allem zeitlicher Aufwand.
Ja gut, das ist etwas... Wir haben mal versucht, hier in Deutschland eine Arbeitserlaubnis zu bekommen. Da haben wir auch mal Leute bei begleitet. Eigentlich wäre es ja gut, wenn über einen solchen Fall dann eine Diskussion dazu angestoßen würde. Meine Vermutung ist, dass es vielleicht eher dann so war, wie bei irgendwelchen gestrandeten Wahlen, wo man auch über Fischkonsum und Schleppnetze reden hätte können. Aber letztlich ging es darum, dass die da oben den nicht retten. Und jetzt liegt er trotzdem am ehrensgründigen Grund. Aber gut.
Einige Tüchter am Rande, die eigentlich auch noch ganz nett sind. Es ist häufiger, dass Profifußballer aus den Nierlanden ihre Rationalität wechseln, um für andere Mannschaften zu spielen. Das werden wir vor allem auch bei der WM sehen, wenn wir sagen, Stichwort Kürrassau. Es ist sehr interessant, ich glaube, es ist nur ein einziger Spieler von dem aktuellen Nationalkader in Kürrassau geboren. Der legendäre Tachy Chong, man kennt ihn aus Werder Bremen noch in der Saison. Und alle anderen sind eigentlich geboren in den Nierlanden und spielen in der Regel auch dort. Und das sind dann Spieler, die halt gut sind. Die haben hier eine Profi-Ausbildung genossen in der Eredivise und spielen erste Liga, teilweise international. Sind aber halt nicht so gut für die Elftal. Deswegen dachte sie sich, ich habe irgendwo noch einen Opa oder eine Oma in Kürassau. Ich schlage jetzt für die auf. Und das heißt, es wird sehr spannend zu sehen sein, wie diese Eredivise-Elf in Kürassau dann performt. Das ist nur am Rande.
Ja, also das gibt es ja immer wieder bei Staaten mit einer bewegten Kolonialgeschichte, sage ich jetzt mal. Ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, welches Team ist bei der Frauen WM 2022 war, aber da gab es eben auch ein Team, das quasi im Grunde komplett aus Experts bestand. Und HIT müsste das gewesen sein. Genau, HIT. Ich gucke hier in meiner Alten. Oh Gott, sind meine Notizen lang. Meine Güte, was habe ich mir denn damals alles rausgeschrieben? Das ist ja übel. Ja, okay. Aber es müsste HIT gewesen sein.
Aber in der Tat ist es eine sehr unschöne und grausame Kolonialgeschichte, das sei an der Stelle noch erwähnt. Und auch da rege ich mich immer drüber auf, dass seitens der Liga-Entschuldigungen auch kaum noch eine offizielle Entschuldigung gekommen ist. Man tut sich mal ein bisschen da vor rum. Noch so eine Seite Geschichte. Man erkennt das schon verklausuliert an, das ganze Unrecht. Aber man ist da immer mit offiziellen Entschuldigungen sehr sparsam. Warum? Das würde nämlich dann bedeuten, dass rechtlich der Weg geschaffen ist für Reparationszahlungen. Bei allen Entschuldigungen, die man tut, reichen die nicht für entsprechende Entschädigungen. Wenn es ans Geld geht, tut es einem anscheinend noch wieder wie in Karleit.
Das kennen wir in Deutschland ja auch. Also könnt ihr einfach mal googeln, was deutsche Bundeskanzler und Präsidenten gesagt haben in der Vergangenheit, zum Beispiel zu Verbrechen der SS, die in Polen begangen wurden oder zu Völkermorden, an denen deutsche Soldaten beteiligt waren. Das ist ein Slalom-Fahren, das hätte Felix Neureuter nicht besser hinbekommen. Immer aus der Angst, dass man was etwas juristisch so Justiziables sagt, dass man dann in Reparationszahlungen reingeht. Aber das ist jetzt, es wird jetzt gerade ein bisschen dark, das merke ich schon, ich ziehe hier. Lasst uns über Fußball sprechen. Wir wollen mal Jakob in die Ligue 1 blicken. Da spitzt sich so langsam in der Tabelle auch so einiges zu. Und wir haben jetzt nicht die Riesenspannung an der Spitze. Sah zwischenzeitlich mal so aus, es sind jetzt weiter 6 Punkte Vorsprung für PSG, Forlence, aber dafür gibt es einen anderen Bereich in der Tabelle, an dem wird es spannend.
Genau, es sind nicht die Giganten, sondern es ist von Platz 3 bis Platz 7 extrem spannend. Also der Kampf um Europa, er ist in vollem Gange. Und es ist dann Lyon auf Platz 3, die haben 60 Punkte und es geht bis runter auf Platz 7 zu Marseille. Die haben 53 Punkte. Und da fragt man sich jetzt vielleicht so ein bisschen, ob Marseille auf Platz 7. Denn ich glaube, als wir das letzte Mal über sie gesprochen haben, hatten sie zwar gerade Roberto de Servi rausgeschmissen, waren allerdings, meine ich, noch dritter. Und es ist also tatsächlich nicht alles gut geworden mit der Trainerentlassung. Ziemlich überraschend. Und plötzlich auch unter Abi Bay, dem neuen Trainer, der ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt mit großen Lorbeeren von Startrennen gekommen ist, beziehungsweise da er auch entlassen wurde, der hat eine wirklich verheerende Bilanz bisher in 11 Pflichtspielen. Punkteschnitt von 1,1. Das ist natürlich für Olympique Marseille wirklich scheußlich. In den letzten sechs Spielen gab es nur einen einzigen Sieg und das war auch ein 3-1 gegen MES, die schon abgestiegen sind. Also jetzt auch nicht gerade erfolgreich. Man hat am Wochenende 3-0 gegen Nantes verloren. Also den Tabellen 17., die davor auch nur vier Spiele überhaupt gewonnen hatten in der Liga. Es läuft also wirklich überhaupt nicht. Es brennt wieder an allen Ecken und Enden. Da hilft auch das tolle neue Logo, was man etabliert hat. Also jetzt als Inter-Wordpress-Marseille hilft nicht so wirklich. Und ja, es ist also die Qualifikation für die Champions League ist fast nicht mehr möglich, denn man hat auf Lille die Vierter sind. Das ist der Platz, der für die Quali zur Champions League berechtigt. In Frankreich hat man auch schon fünf Punkte Rückstand bei noch zwei ausstehenden Spielen und noch Stardrennen und Monaco, die auch dazwischen liegen auf den Plätzen 5 und 6. Es ist also sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass man da noch rankommt. Und ja, so ist dann die Lage in Marseille wirklich wieder extrem schlecht. Man wird dann wahrscheinlich jetzt erst mal hoffen, dass man sich überhaupt für Europa qualifiziert, denn so ein bisschen zu den Rahmenbedingungen. Platz 7 reicht auch nicht unbedingt überhaupt fürs europäische Geschäft. Das heißt, man könnte sogar komplett rausfallen. Das hängt davon ab, wer den Pokal gewinnt. Da spielen nämlich Lens gegen Nizza am Pokalfinale. Nizza ist ja ganz unten in der Tabelle. Wenn die gewinnen, nehmen die natürlich den Europa League-Platz. Wenn Lens allerdings den Pokal gewinnt, geht der halt wie in der Bundesliga dann auch auf den 7. Tabellenplatz über. Ein 8er-Platz ist in Frankreich nicht mehr möglich. Ich glaube, in der UEFA-Rangliste liegt man zu weit hinten, sodass man da den 5. Champions League-Platz auf jeden Fall nicht bekommt.
Das hätten die Marseille-Fans eh nicht hinbekommen, PSG die Daumen zu drücken im Finale, oder?
Ja, gut möglich. Und Straßburg müsste man dann ja auch noch die Daumen drücken. Die sind ja in der Conference League noch dabei. Also die sind jetzt rausgefallen, sich über die Liga zu qualifizieren, könnten sich aber über den Gewinn der Conference League natürlich auch noch qualifizieren. Ja, für Marseille ist das Ganze auch angesichts der Finanzen echt nicht gut, denn es verdichtet sich, dass man im Sommer eigentlich alles zu Geld machen muss, was es im Kader so gibt. Das macht natürlich jetzt auch die sportliche Lage nicht unbedingt besser, dass die Spieler auch viel wieder an Wert verlieren. Es gibt wahnsinnig viel Unruhe auch um Mason Greenwood, der immer wieder aussortiert wurde, nicht gut trainieren soll, ja sowieso eine sehr, sehr streitbare Person ist, definitiv. Und dementsprechend ist es bei Marseille, läuft es wirklich nicht gut und der Sommer wird dann noch mal extrem spannend. Da können wir dann aber auch noch mal drauf schauen. Davon profitieren tun natürlich andere Teams. Ich hatte gerade Lyon schon angesprochen, die auf Platz 3 stehen, die haben wirklich eine völlig verrückte Serie hinter sich. Die hatten 13 Spiele gewonnen zwischenzeitlich, dann waren sie 10 Spiele ohne Sieg, jetzt haben sie wieder 5 Spiele am Stück, müssten es gewesen sein, gewonnen. Und haben sich dadurch– ne, 4 Spiele sind es jetzt gewonnen und haben sich dadurch jetzt wieder in eine super Position gebracht. Nachdem es bei denen zwischenzeitlich so aussah, als würden die da komplett rausrutschen aus den europäischen Rängen, sind sie jetzt auf Platz 3 und man kann davon ausgehen, dass sie zumindest einen der beiden Plätze, 3 oder 4, eigentlich behalten werden. Das ist auch echt beeindruckend, was Paulo von Sieger da geschafft hat. Ich glaube, Lyon profitiert vor allem davon, dass sie jetzt auch nicht mehr in der Europa League dabei sind, also wieder den Rhythmus haben, wir spielen eigentlich nur noch am Wochenende. Seitdem läuft es auch wieder merklich besser. Sie sind ja im 8. Finale gegen Sete ausgeschieden in der Europa League. Seitdem haben sie in der Liga auch mit Ausnahme des Spiels gegen Monaco und des Unentschiedenens gegen Angers nur noch gewonnen, haben unter anderem auch bei Paris sogar gewonnen. Also da auch ein paar echte Achtungserfolge geschafft. Und dann ist es wirklich so ein bisschen eine Geschichte, die sich durchzieht, dass die Teams, die um Europa spielen, alle so ein bisschen Serien haben. Monaco auf Platz 6, die waren ja zwischenzeitlich mal im Tabellen-Mittelfeld verschwunden, haben dann auch eine richtig gute Serie hingelegt, hatten jetzt so ein bisschen stotternd wieder den ganzen Motor, sodass bei denen sah es zwischenzeitlich so aus, okay, die schaffen bestimmt noch die Champions League. Jetzt ist das auch wieder so ein bisschen in die Ferne gerückt, bei Startrennen war ja, wie ich schon eben erwähnt hatte, gab es die Entlassung von Abi Bey, seitdem ist Franck Ass da Trainer, unter dem läuft es wirklich deutlich besser, der hat einen Punkteschnitt von über 2, also für die hat sich der Trainerwechsel definitiv gelohnt, eines der wenigen Teams jetzt in dieser Saison in Frankreich, bei dem es wirklich einen Trainer-Effekt gab, die spielen auch echt coolen Fußball, also total spektakuläre Spiele jetzt unter Franck Ass, also voll offenes Visier. Haben wir jetzt am Wochenende zum Beispiel 2 zu 4 zwar verloren gegen Lyon, aber das war auch ein richtig gutes Spiel mit auch schönen Toren. Die haben mit Esteban Lepol auch den Top-Torjäger in Frankreich, der 19 Tore gemacht hat. Das ist auch eine sehr schöne Geschichte. Der ist nämlich so ein bisschen der Olivier Giroud oder der Miroslav Klose, also so ein Spätstarter auf jeden Fall. Der spielt eigentlich erst seit der letzten Saison wirklich in der Ligue 1 eine Rolle, kommt ursprünglich aus der Lyon-Jugend, hat sich dann über die unteren Ligen hochgearbeitet, ist dann im Sommer von Angers zu Stade Rennes gewechselt und ist jetzt halt wie gesagt für einer der Torschützenliste, wird da auch die Torjägerkanone höchstwahrscheinlich einfahren, denn Panicelli, der hinter ihm steht, ist ja verletzt und hat aber trotzdem angesichts der Stärke des französischen Nationalteams jetzt nicht unbedingt die Perspektive noch auf den WM-Zug oder den WM-Flieger aufzuspringen. Ich glaube, ein Leid, was er ja mit vielen französischen Offensivspielern dann teilt.
Aber wie schön, dass die Liga of All liegen, dass die diejenige ist, wo jemand, der einfach so durchgerutscht ist und nicht im Nachwuchs schon mit 16, 17, 18 der begnadete Fußballer war, dass der Torjäger, also bester Torjäger, hoffentlich werden wird. Das ist schon eine schöne Geschichte, muss man echt sagen.
Ja, und er ist auch so ein bisschen ein Spieler, also so ein Stürmer der alten Schule. Er ist jetzt nicht sonderlich groß, also ist kein Brecher, ist aber jetzt auch nicht so ein herausragender Dribbler oder ein super schneller Spieler, sondern er ist einfach ein Stürmer mit einer wahnsinnig guten Abschlussqualität, einem richtig guten Näschen, einer sauberen Technik. Und ich bin gespannt, ob der noch da bleibt oder wo es ihn noch hintreibt im Laufe seiner Karriere. Ich meine, Giroud war ja auch so ein Spätstarter. Der hat dann ja auch in den späteren Jahren seiner Karriere noch so einiges hinbekommen. Also vielleicht ist dieser Weg ja auch für Esteban LePol möglich. Und um dann noch kurz über den letzten Kandidat für Europa zu sprechen, das ist Lille. Auch die hatten so zu Jahresbeginn eine Phase, wo es so aussah, als würde Bruno Genesio sogar kurz vor der Entlassung stehen. Da haben sie auch sich echt wahnsinnig schwergetan. Dann haben sie aber unter ihm den Umschwung geschafft. Also da war gar kein Trainerwechsel nötig und sind jetzt auch wieder richtig gut dabei. Haben jetzt zwar am Wochenende auch ein ärgerliches Unentschieden nur dabei gehabt, aber stehen halt trotzdem noch in einer guten Position, sich zu qualifizieren. Zumindest für die Quali der Champions League, das ist ja durchaus möglich. Die haben auch einen sehr spannenden Spieler, das ist Matthias Fernandes Pardo. Der ist eigentlich ein Flügelspieler, hat jetzt aber in den letzten Monaten vorrangig auch als Stürmer gespielt und da eben den eben angesprochenen Olivier Giroud verdrängt auf die Bank, der jetzt nur noch als Joker kommt. Davon profitiert die ganze Mannschaft, denn Giroud ist schon körperlich jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt in der Lage, über längere Zeit der die Sturmspitze zu geben und Fernandes Pardo ist wirklich ein extrem spannender Spieler, der für Spanien und Belgien spielen könnte. Ich bin mir gerade gar nicht sicher, ob der jetzt überhaupt schon sich entschieden hat, für welche Nationalmannschaft er spielt, aber er hat auf jeden Fall ein echtes, ja so ein super spannendes Gesamtpaket und ist super schnell, richtig stark im Dribbling, hat aber auch körperlich eine gute Wucht, also ist auch 1,88 groß, was einen aber so ein bisschen überrascht, weil er wirklich so schnell und wendig ist, dass einem das überhaupt nicht auffällt, dass er dann auch noch relativ viel Größe mitbringt und ja, der ist wirklich ein ganz, ganz heißes Eisen, also auf den sollte man auf jeden Fall ein Auge haben mit 21 und jetzt seiner wirklichen Durchbruchssaison bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt. 13 Scorer-Punkte jetzt in der Ligue 1 allein, 8 Tore davon, das ist schon eine echt gute Quote für so einen jungen Spieler, hat noch nicht gespielt für eine Nationalmannschaft, hat für die spanischen UN-Nationalmannschaften gespielt, könnte für Belgien spielen, seine Mutter ist aber auch Italienerin, also mal schauen, wo wir ihn dann später sehen werden.
Aber hat er eine Arbeitserlaubnis? Das ist das einzige, was mich interessiert.
Ja, das müsste man noch mal in die Recherche gehen.
Okay, also Matthias Fernandes Pardo, schauen wir mal, also von dem werden wir wahrscheinlich noch hören. Später meistens auf dem Flügel, auch viel links gehen.
Jetzt aber am Sturmzentrum auch viel.
Okay, das ist jetzt quasi die... Okay, also das wird auf jeden Fall interessant, vor allem weil es gibt auch noch direkte Duelle, das ist ja eigentlich fast logisch, wenn so viele Teams miteinander konkurrieren. Also Lille wird jetzt dann in Monaco spielen, zum Beispiel am nächsten Spieltag. Rennes wird noch gegen Marseille spielen am letzten Spieltag. Ich glaube, das sind jetzt die wichtigsten direkten Duelle.
Lyon spielt noch gegen Lens, die ja aber die Champions League-Quality eigentlich schon sicher haben. Aber gerade Marseille startet Rennes am letzten Spieltag, ist natürlich sehr, sehr pikant, wenn Abib Bey dann auf sein Ex-Team trifft.
Auch noch natürlich im Velo-Drom, also auswärts in Marseille wird das dann stattfinden. Ja, kann sein, dass wir davon doch mal hören. Schauen wir doch einfach mal. Okay, das ist die Situation in der Ligue 1. Dann wollen wir mal nach England blicken, Chris. Wir haben es ja ganz am Anfang der Sendung schon indirekt getan mit Arsenal, aber jetzt widmen wir uns einem Team, bei dem läuft es gar nicht. Das hat man aber in Deutschland auch immer mal wieder so halb mitbekommen, denn da spielt ein sehr prominenter Spieler. Was ist los bei Newcastle?
Ja, Newcastle steht so ein bisschen an einem ganz, ja, interessanten Punkt seit der Übernahme durch den Saudi-Arabischen Public Investment Fund, also so ein bisschen am Scheideweg, könnte man schon sagen. Man hatte ja eigentlich den Anspruch, bis 2030 zur Fußball-Weltelite zu gehören. Realität ist jetzt aber nach Platz 4, 7 und 5 ist man jetzt auch im 13. Platz und es sieht gar nicht gut aus. Das hat einige Gründe bzw. es hat auch einige Gründe, warum man jetzt so ein bisschen am Scheideweg ist mit diesem Projekt, denn es gibt so ein wenig Unruhe, weil es beim PIF, also beim Public Investment Fund, so eine gewisse Kursänderung gab in den letzten Monaten. Am 1. Hervorzuheben ist der Rückzug aus dem Lüft-Golf-Projekt, das ja damals gegründet wurde. Da hat man ja 5 Milliarden reingebuttert, hat man jetzt aufgehört. Auch die WTA-Finals der Frauen werden jetzt nicht mehr in Saudi-Arabien stattfinden. Al Hilal wurde verkauft, die Snooker-Masters wurden abgesagt. Also bei den Sport-Investments zieht man sich so ein bisschen zurück und da stellt sich auch so ein bisschen die Frage, wie wichtig ist ihnen noch Newcastle United? Und da gibt es auch eine ganz interessante Zahl, die das so ein bisschen verdeutlicht, wie wichtig oder welche Priorität der Verein für sie genießt. Alleine der Golfer John Rahm kostete mehr als Newcastle United.
Ehrlich?
Also es wird geschätzt zwischen 300 und 500 Millionen und Newcastle war 300 Millionen.
Oh Gott, ey, diese Lift, das ist so ein Moloch.
Und wenn wir zwei Golfer zusammennehmen, sind wir beim Gesamtinvest in Newcastle United bisher, weil da sind wir bei 800 Millionen.
Okay, und das kann ich vielleicht noch gerade einordnen. Also der Public Investor von Saudi-Arabien, der hatte zwei Billionen, wurde immer so gemunkelt, hatte der in seinem Portfolio, als sie quasi angefangen haben, die ganzen Dinge zu kaufen. Das letzte, was sie jetzt investiert haben, war der Kauf von Electronic Arts für 55 Milliarden US-Dollar. Und da gab es schon Berichte im November, 25 war das von der New York Times, dass eben so langsam dem Fonds jetzt dann doch das Geld ausgeht, auch durchaus verbunden mit der Weltlage und so weiter und so fort. Haben wir ja alle mitbekommen.
Und Riat Air.
Genau. Sie mussten ein Flugzeug für Riat Air kaufen, damit sie mal fliegen können. Das hat sie über die Klippe gepackt. Nein, aber um das mal kurz einzuordnen, da ging das los. Und jetzt sehen wir es eben mit der Liv Golf Serie. Jeder, der sich dafür interessiert, der hat das sowohl damals mitbekommen, als die gegründet wurde, als auch jetzt, wo es zu Ende geht. Aber nur, um quasi die Dimension klar zu machen. Wir sprechen hier bei EA Sports von 55 Milliarden, die sie noch hatten. Und deswegen finde ich das jetzt aber interessant, dass das tatsächlich sich bei Newcastle auszuwirken scheint oder auswirken könnte, wenn wir davon in Anführungszeichen nur 800 Millionen sprechen. Das ist aus Sicht des Staatsfonds ja eigentlich gar nichts.
Genau, also um das jetzt auch so ein bisschen, ja, die Panik ein bisschen zu mildern. Es heißt, dass man noch voll in dem Projekt involiert sein ist, dass es keine, dass es ein klares Bekenntnis gibt zum Investment und auch, dass es zur Strategie passt, dass man so ein bisschen mehr auf langfristige Investments schauen will. Denn man muss dazu sagen, Newcastle wurde damals relativ günstig gekauft. Ich meine, es waren um die 100 noch was Millionen. Und das ist ja für einen Verein wie Newcastle United, der wirklich eine große Fanbase hat, Premier League, etc., relativ günstig. Und es ist ein langfristiges Investment. Und anscheinend hat man sich jetzt dazu bekannt. Nichtsdestotrotz müssen jetzt auch allmählich Taten folgen, denn nicht nur wegen den anderen Investments gibt man so ein bisschen nervös in Newcastle. Man sieht auch, es gab immer wieder Gespräche über ein neues Stadion, über einen neuen Trainingszentrum und so weiter. Passiert ist bisher sehr, sehr wenig. Bis gar nichts. Es gibt zwar einen Ort jetzt für den neuen Trainingskomplex, aber klare Daten gibt es bisher auch nicht oder klar kommunizierte Pläne gibt es auch nicht, geschweige denn vom Stadion. Und ja, deswegen gibt es da so ein bisschen Unruhe, wie sehr der Investment-Fondant noch an Newcastle United interessiert ist. Das heißt allerdings nicht, dass man auch schon einiges erreicht hat. Man hat 500 Millionen in den Kader investiert, man hat den Umsatz verdoppelt oder mehr als verdoppelt und wie gesagt, zweimal Champions League, einmal Liga-Pokal-Sieg, das ist jetzt nicht nichts, aber nichtsdestotrotz hinkt es dem Gesamtziel, da diese Weltelite, wahrscheinlich Meisterschaften, Champions League und so weiter, natürlich mächtig hinterher. Und das hat zum einen, wird da immer wieder die Ausrede benutzt, dass einem durch den PSA, also die englische Financial Fair Play-Regelung, so ein bisschen die Hände gebunden waren. Dazu gehört aber auch, dass man einfach zu wenig getan hat, sprich, man hat zu schlecht verkauft. Und vor allem, was man so hört, gerade in England reiben sich manche Konkurrenten die Augen, dass Newcastle viel zu wenig für die Kommunizierung gemacht hat, viel zu wenig was Sponsoring angeht, Marketing. Also da wurde, der Ausdruck, der benutzt wird ist, da wurde zu viel Geld auf den Tisch gelassen. Und da hätte man den Umsatz nochmal deutlich steigern können. Und dann hätte man auch weniger Probleme mit dem Financial Fair Play gehabt und hätte auch mehr investieren können. Also das ist so ein bisschen immer der Vorwand, der genutzt wird. Aber ganz so greifbar ist er meines Erachtens auch nicht.
Ja, das ist schon, das ist schon tatsächlich interessant. Also sie sind bei den bei den Einnahmen eben aus Nicht-Transfers. Da liegen sie auf Platz 7 in der Premier League. Und da muss man ja noch sagen, da ist ja einiges quasi noch positiv gerechnet durch eben überteuerte Sponsoring, die sie haben. Also da haben wir ja quasi auch Reard Air Reloaded. Das ist schon am Matchday machen sie 58 Millionen. Das war jetzt 23, 24. Das sind die letzten Zahlen, die ich jetzt gerade hier habe. Zum Vergleich Tottenham, die Spurs, die jetzt auch nicht gerade vor Kraft laufen, nicht laufen können aktuell. Die machen einfach genau das Doppelte durch ihre Einnahmen. Natürlich auch neue Stadion und so weiter. Aber da siehst du eben, welches Geld da auf dem Tisch liegen gelassen wird. Ja, das ist schon interessant. Und was glaubst du, bedeutet das jetzt sportlich für Newcastle? Also müssen sie dann Anthony Gordon an die Bayern verkaufen, die Armen?
Also ich habe ja gerade schon gesagt, es wurden trotzdem gute Summen in den Kader investiert. Dazu muss man jetzt aber auch sagen, nicht sonderlich clever. Es ist nicht nur das Geld, es ist sondern wie das Geld investiert wurde. Und zuletzt lief es bei Newcastle United gar nicht. Man hatte neun sieglose Spiele aus zwölf und zuletzt fünf Niederlagen in Folge. Der Sieg gegen Brighton am Wochenende war da hingehend sehr, sehr wichtig, weil es ein bisschen den Druck wegnahm. Vor allem, weil eine 25-köpfige Delegation aus Saudi-Arabien zu Besuch war. Und da ging es natürlich auch so ein bisschen um die Analyse der aktuellen sportlichen Lage. Also es war ein geplanter Besuch. So viel dazu, es war jetzt kein Krisengespräch. Und da ging es auch um Eddie Howe, der jetzt bleiben wird. Und man sieht auch, warum er bleibt, denn er ist unbedingt dafür verantwortlich. Alleine ein Blick auf die Bank am Wochenende zeigt, da waren 388 Millionen Euro auf der Bank. Und da sieht man schon, wie der letzte Transfersummer gelaufen ist. Nämlich gar nicht. Da kommen wir auch gleich zu Nick Rolte-Made. Man hat sich so ein bisschen das eigene Transferfenster torpediert durch die Alexander-Isaac-Geschichte. Klar, man hat eine britische Rekordsumme bekommen mit 150 Millionen. Hat ihn aber wirklich viel zu spät verkauft. Und dann gab es viele Paniktransfers. Es gab einige Absagen auf dem Transfermarkt. Und ja, rauspicken kann man so Elanga, 60 Millionen Euro, einen Scorer-Punkt, Wissar von Renford, 60 Millionen, einen Tor. Nick Voltemade geht sogar noch mit, ich glaube, 7 Toren, 75 Millionen. Aber 6 Tore davon waren in den ersten 10 Spielen. Und dementsprechend sieht man, dass der Transfer-Sommer eine einzige Katastrophe war. Und auch die Sommer davor war nicht ideal. Klar, der eine Sommer, da wurden einem so ein bisschen die Hände gebunden durch den PSA. Aber insgesamt hat man an 5 Transferfenstern in Folge nichts für die Startelf getan. Und dementsprechend ist das mittlerweile ein Kader, der in die Jahre gekommen ist, dem es hinten und vorne an Qualität fehlt. Und der auch nicht für 55-plus Pflichtspiele diese Saison gemacht ist. Und das hat man diese Saison gesehen. Es war nicht diese typische Newcastle-Intensität, Energie, die Eddie How auszeichnet oder die How-Mannschaften auszeichnet. Und da ging man schon ordentlich auf den Zahnfleisch. Und es muss jetzt einiges passieren. Und jetzt, um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, ja, Spieler wie Anthony Gordon müssen verkauft werden. Es gibt da einige Verkaufskandidaten. Anthony Gordon, Tonali, Bruno Gamaraj, Livra Mento. Es müssen Spieler verkauft werden, denn es muss so viel in diesem Kader passieren. Torwart, Abwehrspieler in Verteidigung, ein echten Stürmer, ein Flügelspieler. Und deswegen ist das Ganze so ein bisschen ein Teufelskreis, um das Projekt wieder auf die richtige Bahn. Ich benutze das Projekt nicht gern, aber es ist einfach bei Newcastle so. Um das Video auf die richtige Bahn zu führen, muss man den Kader umkrempeln. Gleichzeitig will man jetzt zur Weltelite gehören und Ergebnisse sehen. Aber das schreit ja eigentlich viel mehr nach einem Jahr oder mehreren Jahren der Transition. Und das führt dann wieder zur Frage, wie geduldig sind die Investoren, wie geduldig sind die Fans, denen einfach viel mehr versprochen wurde. Und deswegen droht das Ganze so ein bisschen, um Pulverfass zu werden und es ist einfach jetzt ein unfassbar wichtiger Sommer für den ganzen Verein.
Also total interessante Situation bei Newcastle. Noch dazu, weil man natürlich da auch sehr, also da kann man ja auch moralische Diskussionen und so weiter drüber führen, haben wir ja hier auch oft genug gemacht in der Ligatour. Aber die komplette Situation des Vereins, auch wirtschaftlich gesehen, ist so unterdurchschnittlich, unter Premier League Niveau. Also Matchday habe ich ja schon genannt, irgendwie Hälfte von den Spurs. Aber Commercial-Einnahmen, also eben durch Sponsoren, Newcastle United 23, 24, 77 Millionen Pfund. Und, ja, kann ich mir mal rausnehmen, ja, nehm mal wieder die Spurs, 256, also quasi mehr als das Dreifache. Und natürlich ganz oben sind dann eben Teams wie, wenn ich jetzt in der Premier League bleibe, eben City 350 Millionen, United 310 Millionen. Da ist positiv gesehen, liegt da ein irres Potenzial. Vielleicht ist der Markt von Newcastle aber auch nicht so groß wie von anderen Franchises, die schon weg waren, sag ich jetzt einfach mal. Jakob, du wolltest noch was ergänzen?
Ich finde vor allem, wenn man sich die Transfers anschaut, auch nochmal krass, dass ich auch da glaube, dass, also zumindest wenn man sich anschaut, wen Newcastle so holt, dass man auch nicht das Gefühl hat, dass die sportliche Leitung in irgendeiner Art und Weise Premier League tauglich aufgestellt ist. Denn sie holen ja auch eigentlich nur Spieler, die ich dir jetzt auch bei FIFA scouten könnte, ohne dass ich groß irgendwas über irgendwelchen Fußball weiß. Und das ist ja schon, hat man ja gerade auch in der Premier League gesehen, dass dann die Vereine, die auch ein bisschen out of the box denken, bei Transfers, sich dadurch dann auch nochmal Vorteile erarbeiten, wie zum Beispiel auch Brighton und so weiter und so fort, dass man dadurch ja auch diese ganzen finanziellen Hürden umgeht, indem man einfach nicht nur teure Spieler holt, sondern vielleicht nicht günstige Spieler, aber halt Spieler, die nicht so völlig überbezahlt werden müssen. Und da sind halt, finde ich es halt auch komisch, dass dann immer die Diskussion so an Nick Woltemade aufgehangen wird. Denn wie Chris gerade schon gesagt hat, also Elanga, Wisser und Ramsey sind ja eigentlich drei, vier schlimmere Fälle. Von denen hat keiner mehr als 40 Prozent der Minuten gespielt in dieser Saison und die haben alle mindestens 45 Millionen gekostet. Das ist schon dann auch echt eine absolute Fehlleistung auf dem Transfermarkt. Da liegt jetzt aber auch so ein bisschen die Hoffnung auf Besserung, denn letzten Sommer hatte man tatsächlich keinen Geschäftsführer und keinen Sportdirektor während der Transferphase. Das hat sich mittlerweile geändert. David Hopkinson ist CEO, Sportdirektor ist Ross Wilson. Und wie man so hört, hat man dieses Jahr deutlich früher mit der Rekrutierungsphase begonnen, hat eine klare Strategie ausgelegt, ob die dann auch umgesetzt werden kann. Das ist eine andere Frage, denn das passt wieder zu diesen Versprechungen, die getätigt wurden. Also in die Athletik war ein Bericht, dass ein Anthony Gordon oder ein Tonali, die wurden auch damit überzeugt, dass man hier ein ganz krasses Projekt startet, mit einem neuen Stadion, mit einem neuen Trainingskomplex etc. Und passiert ist nichts. Und wenn man Spielern so etwas erklärt, das spricht sich ja auch rum. Und da eingehen muss man mal schauen, welche Anziehungskraft Newcastle auf dem Transfermarkt jetzt überhaupt haben wird im Sommer. Denn es gab viele Absagen letzten Sommer schon. Dann sieht man, was diesen Sommer passiert ist, was jetzt generell passiert ist im Verein und dass dieses Unruhe herrscht auch so ein bisschen. Also da muss Newcastle ein bisschen erfinderischer werden, definitiv.
Esteban Le Paul kann ich Ihnen empfehlen, wenn Sie mal unkonventionell denken wollen. Wobei eigentlich wäre es so ein alter Transfer, hat jetzt eine gute Saison und dann greifen sie zu. Wisst ihr übrigens noch so ein kleines Wissensnugget, wer ist nach Minuten der Spieler, der am meisten eingesetzt wurde bei Newcastle United? Malik Csau. Der alte Schalke, Schalke einfach. Eine Macht, aber das wissen wir ja. Ich würde sagen, wir gehen in unsere schnelleren Runden und da würde ich doch dann vorstellen, ob wir nochmal nach Spanien gehen wollen. Nils, du hast schon am längsten jetzt nichts mehr hier beitragen dürfen. Und das, obwohl wir ja einen Sensations-Transfer haben. In der letzten Ligatur, wo haben wir da Terzic nochmal hingesprochen? Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht mehr. Also wir sind auf jeden Fall auf Iraola. Das war quasi unser Guess für Bilbao. Ich weiß nicht mal, auf jeden Fall kaum war sie veröffentlicht. Die letzte Folge hieß es dann Terzic zu Atletik und jetzt ist es auch tatsächlich so gekommen. Was wird beide Seiten da erwarten?
Hat sich jetzt tatsächlich seit Wochen angebahnt. Jetzt wurde es publik gemacht und erstmal kann man sagen La Liga goes Bundesliga. Wir haben da schon Hansi Flick, Matarazzo auch. Riesen-Erfolgsgeschichte mit der Copa del Rey und da jetzt ein Erdin Terzic, was für mich auch erstmal überraschend war, weil ich hätte auch Geld gesetzt auf Iraola. Aber ja, man scheint da mit Terzic schon früh einer Meinung gewesen sein. Da gibt es wohl diesen Sportdirektor, Mikkel González, der sich da schon lange um ihn bemüht haben soll. Er ist jetzt seit zwei Jahren, glaube ich, im sabbatical und er geht von einem besonderen Klub. Jeder ist besonders und hat eine besondere Fan-Niue, aber Dortmund ist ja schon irgendwas spezielles zu genauso Atletik, die auch was sehr Spezielles sind. Viele wissen ja nicht, Liga, Dino, immer noch ein Verein, Mitglieder geführt und eben auch, ich würde fast sagen, in Bilbao wird Fußball so geliebt wie nirgends. Also da siehst du noch mal mehr Schals. Das ist in Madrid jetzt zum Beispiel nicht so der Fall. Also Bilbao, da schon eine sehr besondere Fußballstadt, aber eben auch ein sehr spezieller Klub, weil jeder weiß ja, jeder Spieler dort hat irgendwie baskische Wurzeln. Das wurde hier und da vielleicht ein bisschen gelockert, aber irgendeinen baskischen Hintergrund braucht man. Also sorry Julian Brandt, Jadon Sancho, das wird schwierig. Aber vielleicht gibt es ja aus dem Niederland ein paar Tipps mit doppelter Staatsbürgerschaft. Also wie gesagt, das wird schon mal sehr speziell. Ich kann es mir mittlerweile gut vorstellen, weil wie gesagt, er ist ja sowohl noch jung und auch eigentlich modern und kann Spieler mitreißen, als auch irgendwie, dass er die Fan-Nähe hinbekommt, dass er da den Funken entzünden kann. Und jetzt eben letztes Beispiel, wie Matarazzo, haben wir gezeigt, dass Bundesliga-Erfahrung was bringen kann. Und noch ein Top, der Atleti-Club hat ja auch schon sehr gute Erfahrungen gehabt mit ausländischen Trainern. Also bei den Spielern, die Philosophie, müssen da aus dem Nachwuchs kommen aus dem Baskenland, ist klar, aber Trainer hat man natürlich schon große Erfolgreiche gehabt aus anderen Ländern. Jupp Heynckes war zweimal da in den 90ern, Anfang der 2000er. Und vor allem ist Bilbao ja auch so ein bisschen die Wiege des Fußball, des spanischen Fußballs, weil von dort kamen Engländer, die haben dann mit dem Fußball quasi angefangen. Jetzt gibt es ein paar englische Erfolgstrainer, unter anderem Frederic Pentland, der bis heute der erfolgreichste Trainer in Atletikshistorie ist. Sprich, man hat da gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Und auch deswegen hat man sich jetzt vielleicht gedacht, gut, mit Edin Terzic, das könnte gut klappen. Ob das dann sportlich dann auch so wird, mal schauen. Weil Atletik hat ja trotzdem auch eine schwierige Saison hinter sich. Könnte es jetzt doch noch nach Europa schaffen, zumindest Europa League. Aber da hat man wie immer Offensivprobleme in dieser Saison gehabt. Nico Williams oft ausgefallen, auch so ein bisschen diese Leistenprobleme, was auch ein Lamine Jamal teilweise hat. Aber der ist jetzt langsam wieder zurück. Trotzdem wird da schon Edin Terzic schauen müssen, dass er wie gesagt nicht einfach Spieler transferieren kann, sondern gucken muss, was im Nachwuchs, was sich da so ergibt oder wo vielleicht doch irgendwo ein Spieler ist mit baskischen Wurzeln, in dem man dann doch mal transferieren kann. Aber ja, schöne Geschichte.
Und was glaubst du, das war jetzt quasi die Sicht von Atletik auf Terzic. Was glaubst du, wird Terzic da leisten müssen? Weil also allein Baskis ist ja schon mal eine Hürde. Nach allem, was ich mitbekommen habe, ist es jetzt nicht so nah. Also das ist einfacher, Katalanisch im Vergleich zu Spanisch zu lernen. Zumindest würde mir das bisher immer so gesagt. Korrigiere mich gerne, wenn es ist. Also was ist da die Herausforderung für ihn?
Das ist auf jeden Fall auch nochmal eine Hürde. Also jetzt denkt sich jeder, gut, es ist halt ein Dialekt. Nee, nee, wir reden wirklich von eigenen Sprachen in Spanien. Ich bin auch oft dort gewesen, auf den Schildern, Verkehrsschildern stehen dann auch einfach andere Wörter. Und nicht Salida-Ausgang ist dann einfach Salid oder wie auch immer. Von dem her, da konnte er sich bestimmt mittlerweile drauf vorbereiten. Mit Englisch kommt man, glaube ich, auch nicht so weit. Schlussendlich ist es aber trotzdem machbar. Inzwischen auch Matarazzo zeigt ja auch, San Sebastian liegt auch im Baskenland und hat dann auch bei der Pokalfeier auch mal baskisch vorgelesen. Klingt komisch alles, aber irgendwie geht es ja trotzdem. Und du hast junge Spieler, die dann vielleicht doch mittlerweile in Englisch besser geschult sind. Aber ja, wird spannend. Wie gesagt, sportlich bleibt da immer das Thema, wie viel Offensivpower kannst du entwickeln, weil nicht so viel aus dem Nachwuchs nachkommt. Trotzdem ist der Athletic Club kassiert in dieser La Liga-Saison die zweitwenigsten Abschlüsse. Also defensiv ist das immer eigentlich ganz stabil. Nächste Saison hat man vielleicht nicht den ganz großen Druck, dass es vielleicht doch keine Doppelbelastung gibt. Sollten sie es jetzt doch nicht nach Europa schaffen. Das steht über allem. Ich glaube, man hat da viel Geduld. Man hat jetzt jahrelang vielleicht schon an ihm gebaggert und ihm viel Vertrauen schon gezeigt und ihn unbedingt haben wollen. Er hat bestimmt auch andere Angebote. Er kann da in Ruhe arbeiten. Ich glaube, er hat nicht den ganz großen Druck. Im Endeffekt geht es für die Athletik auch immer ein bisschen darum, einfach vielleicht auch mal in der Coup de Ré weiterzukommen. Da muss nicht der Europapokal immer zwingend eingeplant werden. Das war jetzt mit Weil werde wieder eine erfolgreiche Zeit. Coup de Ré ja auch gewonnen nach 40 Jahren mal wieder ein Titel. Aber ich glaube, für den Terzic ist es ein ruhiges Umfeld mehr oder weniger, wo er sich was aufbauen kann, wo er viel Vertrauen genießt. Lebensqualität ist sehr hoch. Das genießt ja auch Matarazzo in St. Sebastian. Von dem her, glaube ich, könnte das schon Win-Win irgendwo sein.
Stark. Wir werden es auf jeden Fall verfolgen hier in der Ligatur. Und wenn wir schon bei Teams sind, die im Pokal ja vielleicht auch mal den ein oder anderen Erfolg feiern könnten, dann können wir auch in die Serie A blicken zu Lazio. Chris, wir hatten es das letzte Mal schon. Eduardo Motta. Ich habe mir dann nach unserer Sendung auch das Elfmeterschieß nochmal angeguckt. Das war wirklich genauso dramatisch, wie du es beschrieben hattest. Aber es bietet jetzt eigentlich einen ganz guten Moment, nochmal ein bisschen größer auf Lazio zu blicken und eben nicht nur auf die Torhüterpersonalie. Was funktioniert da denn gerade, dass man es ins Finale geschafft hat? Und in der Liga? Gut, man spielt jetzt zweimal in Folge quasi gegen Inter. Ich weiß nicht, wie das Ligaspiel jetzt dann zu bewerten ist, aber wie steht es um Lazio?
Genau, gehen wir gleich zu Lazio. Ich habe nur ganz kurz am Anfang Fernandes Pardo, weil er vorhin schön thematisiert wurde. Wer glaubt ihr, welcher italienische Club hat da schon, ich sage mal, Kontakte geknüpft, wenn ihr einen nennen wollen würdet? Como. Sehr gut, Max. Genau. Absolut. Como hat den jungen Mann auch auf dem Zettel. Definitiv. Klammer geschlossen. Lazio, Maurizio Sarri, sehr spannend. Einstiegsmäßig, wenn wir uns die Tabelle der letzten 8 Spieltage hernehmen, in der Serie A, hat Lazio die zweitmeisten Punkte geholt. Nur Juve hat einen Punkt mehr geholt. Lazio ist sogar mehr als Inter. Die haben sich jetzt gefangen, haben von den letzten zehn Pflichtspielen nur ein einziges verloren, haben in der Liga Napoli auswärts geschlagen, haben Milan geschlagen. Genau, das Eduardo Motta Märchen hat man ja schon. Maurizio Sarri hat die jetzt in die Spur bekommen. Warum wir eben darüber reden, Max hat sie schon kurz angeteased, kommenden Mittwoch ist Coppa Italia-Finale. Das lautet eben Lazio gegen Inter. Das ist für Lazio jetzt die große Chance, Europa noch klar zu machen. Denn in der Liga werden sie es nicht mehr schaffen, obwohl sie sich jetzt gefangen haben. Aber der Liga-Weg ist, ich glaube, sie sind im Moment auf 7 oder 8. Also, wenn sie dieses Pokalfinale gewinnen, dann spielen sie europäisch, ansonsten eben nicht. Und das ist schon ein sehr spannender Ding, nur ganz kurzer Klammer. Vielleicht erinnert euch noch, Lazio hatte vergangenen Sommer eine Transfersperre, eine italienisch auferlegt. Also in Italien gibt es ähnlich wie in Spanien, wenn man gewisse wirtschaftliche Parameter reist, dann kann die Liga eingreifen. Lazio durfte wirklich keinen einzigen Transfer tätigen. Und hat dann im Winter auch noch Gendouzi verkauft, Castellanos in die Premier League und Mandas auch in die Premier League, den Torhüter. Nicht umsonst hat Maurizio Sarri in der Saison gesprochen und ihr wisst, der sehr lange schon dabei ist, die mit Abstand schwerste Saison meines Trainerlebens. Also wirklich eine ganz besondere. Aber irgendwie hat er sie jetzt wieder hinbekommen sozusagen. Im Winter kam für Daniel Vaz, Daniel Taylor von Ajax. Den hat er jetzt gut eingearbeitet. Er hat eben diese defensive Stabilität wieder. Lazio steht sehr gut. Eben Mota hatten wir schon oft zu Null. Also dieses Sarri-Positionsspiel, das wir noch aus Napoli-Zeiten kennen. Das ist ja schon auch eine Kombination aus schönem ansehendem Fußball, aber schon auch defensiver Stabilität. Das hat er jetzt langsam wieder implementiert bekommen aus den wirklich schweren Transfer-Umständen. Was ich ganz spannend fand zuletzt, Sarri hat auch selbst gesagt, eigentlich kommt über Ballbesitz, über sein Positionsspiel wie gesagt historisch gesehen, aber er hat gesagt, ich habe jetzt hier einen Kader, der nicht ganz diese Qualitäten hat, sondern der ein bisschen spritzigerer Kader ist, dynamischerer Kader und er hat seinen Stil angepasst. Was ich ja schon respektabel finde für einen Mann wie Sarri, der schon so lange im Geschäft ist. Er hat verstanden, dass seine Grundideen mit diesem Lazio-Kader, den er ja 0,0 beeinflussen konnte, aber wie gesagt, er konnte keinen einzigen neuen holen, außer Taylor jetzt im Winter, hat er sich auch ein bisschen auf die Spieler angepasst. Das trägt jetzt Früchte. Ein, zwei Namen nenne ich kurz nun oder wahrisch. Erinnert euch vielleicht noch, vor eineinhalb Jahren war der, der mit Fede Di Marco, der herausfragende Außenverteidiger in der Serie A, ist da bei Lazio links rauf und runter, assistmaschine, der hat sich dann eine komplette Rückrunde und jetzt in der Saison eine komplette Hinrundepause genommen. Der war wirklich komplett weg. Sarri hat den auch komplett rausgelassen, gesagt, du bist zu schwach im Moment. Du musst dich defensiv steigern. Das hat er gemacht. Und jetzt sieht man in den letzten Wochen wieder den Tavares mit diesem krassen Antritt, der da viel auch aus dem Stand draus einfach mit, ja, mit Explosivität löst. Taylor eben, wie gesagt, der hat funktioniert gut, den hat er gut eingearbeitet. Noch für Daniel war es niederländisches, Dijani Noslin, vielleicht sagt ein paar was. Den haben sie von Lazio geholt. Der hat lange nicht so funktioniert, Offensivspieler, den hat Sarri jetzt auch in die Spur bekommen. Also ja, es ist wirklich, ich glaube, Sarri hat auf einem anderen Niveau. Logischerweise ist das jetzt nicht sportlich das Niveau, was er mit Napoli hatte, aber ich glaube, die Schwierigkeit der Aufgabe, die er in dieser Saison zu bewältigen hatte, ist das eine seiner größten Leistungen. Und sollte Lazio das zur Erinnerung, das Pokalfinale in Italien ist ja immer in Rom, also Lazio hat da schon zumindest vom Umfeld her Heimvorteil. Ansonsten sind es ja 50-50, sind die diese wunderschönen Bilder, wo komplette Kurve Inter, komplette Kurve Lazio. Also logisch ist es 50-50 im Stadion, aber der ein oder andere Römer mehr wird dann schon im Stadion sein, würde ich mal vermuten und deswegen ist es eine schöne Geschichte, dass Lazio und Sarri jetzt die Chance haben, dadurch einen Pokalsieg, auch wenn sie logisch Außenseiter sind gegen Inter. Ja, die Saison jetzt schon in der richtig guten Richtung nochmal zu lenken.
Das kann man sich auf jeden Fall angucken. Wirst du dabei zu hören sein?
Ja, freue ich mich drauf. Genau, ja, genau. Also Pokalfinal in Rom ist wirklich immer was sehr Besonderes. Letzter Satz dazu, vor allen Dingen die Grundgeschichte haben wir auch schon hier thematisiert. Die Lazio-Fans und Loditos sind ja schon seit Monaten auf Kriegsfuß. Also zuletzt gab es Heimspiele, wo die Kurve komplett die Heimspiele brakodiert hat. Ich glaube, es gab jetzt mal ein Lazio-Heimspiel mit 12.000 Zuschauern. Aber für das Pokalfinale haben sie logischerweise gesagt, da wollen wir bei der Mannschaft sein. Also da kommen sie auch. Aber ansonsten gibt es da in der Vereins-Ebene, da müsste man jetzt tief eintauchen. Also es ist wirklich auf allen Ebenen eine ganz besondere Saison für Lazio. Und dass Sarri jetzt und die Spieler sportlich jetzt die Chance haben, da wirklich noch was Großes zu machen, finde ich, kann man ihnen sportlich in dem Moment auf jeden Fall hoch anregen.
Also wenn hier die Zahlen stimmen, die ich gerade habe, dann hatte man Heimspiele mit 1.800 Zuschauern, mit 5.000 Zuschauern, mit 2.000 Zuschauern und jetzt gegen Udini mit 4.000 zuschauern, auch tatsächlich.
Also es ist immer die Frage, wie viele dann von den Dauerkarten– das waren, glaube ich, die verkauften Karten– wie viele dann sonst noch drin waren. Aber ja, es ist wirklich sehr– also es war ein Geisterspiel, Atmosphäre. Und jetzt, weil du es ja sagst, am Wochenende ist ja nochmal Lazio-Inter in der Liga, bevor es dann eben am Mittwoch ins Pokalfinale geht. Da ist dieser Streik auch weiterhin aufrechterhalten. Also da wird das Olympico anders ausschauen als dann am Mittwoch. Da wird es schön glänzen.
Okay, also das kann man sich auf jeden Fall alles angucken, vor allem das Pokalfinale, würde ich dann unter diesen Bedingungen tatsächlich sagen. Und dann ist aber ja die Liga nicht die einzige Liga, in der jetzt sich noch die letzten europäischen Plätze ausgespielt werden, sondern dann in den Niederlanden ist es ganz ähnlich. Wie sieht es denn da aus?
Genau, wir haben ein sehr, sehr enges Rang auf Platz 3, 4 und 5. Das sind Nijmegen mit 56 Punkten, Ajax mit 55 und Zwente auch mit 55. Also das für alle drei noch alles drin in den letzten zwei Spieltagen. Und ich gebe jetzt eine kleine Prognose ab. Ich glaube, dass der Stand, der jetzt da ist, auch der ist, den wir in zwei Wochen dann sehen. Und das Ziel von allen, also das Objekt der BG hier, sage ich mal, ist Platz 3. Weil Platz 3 qualifiziert für die CL-Quali, Platz 4 qualifiziert für die EL-Quali und Platz 5 ist so ein bisschen der Unterbarste von den dreien, weil die müssen dann mit dem letzten 6 bis 9 in dieser Saison noch die UCL-Klasse aufspielen. Das heißt, dann geht es dann wieder in den Play-Off-Runden-Liga intern.
Für die Conference League macht man extra noch mal eine Play-Off-Runde auf.
Ja, man muss ja irgendwie so spielen kommen. Man muss ja ein bisschen noch Fernseheinnahmen generieren, das ist ja klar.
Man hätte doch jetzt die Möglichkeit gehabt, noch mal 133 Spiele extra aufzubekommen. Also das verstehe ich jetzt alles gar nicht. Aber gut.
Und genau, und Hazel Alkmaar, die sind auf 6. Die haben aber, die müssen den ganzen Spaß nicht mehr machen, weil die durch den Pokalsieg für die EEL qualifiziert sind. Deswegen ist Alkmaar aus der Rechnung draußen. Und Schalke jetzt würde zum Beispiel dann Twente auf 5, gegen Sparta auf 9 spielen. Also, aber was ich überlege, der Neuen platzierte der Saison hat Chancen, internationale Spiele. Also, ja, das ist, hat man, glaube ich, damals auch eingeführt, um so ein bisschen Spannung zu erzeugen, offiziell. Und offiziell hat man eben dann noch mal weitere Playoffs, die man irgendwie vermarkten kann. Das ist leider in den Niederlanden nicht ganz anders, als in anderen europäischen Ligen. Aber das ist ja nicht das Ziel von Twente. Twente möchte auf Platz 3. Aber ich glaube, dass Nijmegen auf Platz 3 bleibt. Ich hatte sie auch schon mal in der Rasenfunk-Folge, ein bisschen gefeatured. Das war Diki Taka, die Überschrift von Dick Schreuder, dem Trainer von Nijmegen. Und ich finde, dass sie nicht die liebsten Chancen haben, auf Platz 3 zu halten, sondern sie hätten es auch verdient. Also ganz, ganz laut gesagt, erst mal das Programm. Sie müssen noch gegen Groningen und De Winter auf 10 und 11. Da ist schon eine gewisse Stolpergefahr da. Aber grundsätzlich ist es für Nijmegen machbar, würde ich sagen. Und Nijmegen macht auch einfach Spaß und hat Spaß gemacht in der Saison. Also es ist dieses typische Dick-Schreuter-Ball. Also Horus Pressing viel beibezitzt. Dieses Total-Football, das man eigentlich von Ajax kennt, hat Nijmegen in dieser Saison sehr, sehr gut umgesetzt und perfektioniert. Und das Risiko, was sie gehen, war in der Saison gesundheitlich sehr hoch. Die Spiele in der ligenraschen Hälfte und dieses schöne Angriffspressing hat Spaß gemacht. Und sie hatten auch eine Phase, in der sie ungeschlagen waren. Ich glaube, sie hatten in 13 Spielen von November 25 bis Februar 26 11 Siege in zwei Ringen. Das darfst du übergreifen. Davon zählen sie immer noch. Deswegen sind sie auch so weit oben. In den letzten Wochen haben wir so ein bisschen fehlen lassen. Sie hätten zum Beispiel jetzt vergangene Woche auch schon die Punkte ausbauen können. Da haben sie aber gegen Telstar auf 15 Nuremi gespielt. Also das waren so verlorene Punkte. Dann hätten sie sogar noch mal ein bisschen auf das 2 schielen können. Da ist Feynort mit 61 Punkten. So dürfte Feynort relativ fix auf 2 sein. PSV ist sowieso Meister auf 1. Aber ja, also aufgrund dieses Restprogramms von Nijmegen und einfach auch, weil sie es verdient hätten, glaube ich und denke ich, dass sie Platz 3 dann auch halten können. Und dann mal schauen, ob sie die CR-Qualität uns schaffen und uns bereichern. Und bei Ajax würde man sagen, ja, es ist so ein bisschen das, was sie verdient haben. Das klingt jetzt wieder so böse, aber ich meine, man muss überlegen, die Saison von Ajax war ja wieder mal so ein bisschen Katastrophensaison. Also insgesamt statt drei Trainer jetzt schon wieder in der Seitenlinie sind sie mit Heitinga gestartet, der sich da öffentlich ein bisschen verworfen hatte. Er hat sich teilweise auch einfach verkauscht in gewissen Spielen. Und es dann musste gehen. Da hatte man eigentlich gesagt, okay, wir nehmen mit Fred Grimm noch einen Interimstrainer. Also es war von vornherein klar, dass Grimm auch nur bis zum Ende der Saison quasi Ajax irgendwie ein bisschen auf Kurs halten soll. Und nach Möglichkeit, das war eigentlich das Ziel, es ist das Ziel nach wie vor, halt mindestens irgendwie auf drei hiefen zu können. Und es hat er aber auch dann eine kleine Wiesnenserie gehabt und ist dann auch wieder gegangen. Also dann ist der Interimstrainer, der sowieso nur Interimstrainer war, auch gegangen, wieder zurück in die Jugend. Und jetzt haben wir Garcia als Trainer, der war auch nur Interimstrainer. Also bei dem ist auch klar, der wird in der Saison auch nicht dauerhaft bleiben. Also Ajax geht jetzt schon in die Interimstrainer ran, die sich dies hier stellen und feuern sie wieder. Und ich glaube, es ist Ajax fast nur aufgrund der individuellen Qualität zu verdanken, dass sie dann noch Chancen haben, sogar auf die Champions League. Also Mika Hots trifft am laufenden Band, das ist ein belgisches Talent von einem Sturm, wo ich sogar sagen würde, der ist vom Talentstatus her eigentlich schon einen Schritt weiter in der Entwicklung. Du hast David Claassen, den ich hier immer an mich wieder nenne, als wirklich konstanten Spieler. Und du hast einfach ein paar individuelle Spieler, die durch ihre Klasse dann Allachs hier und da noch einen Punkt retten, mal oder den Sieg geben und deswegen haben sie noch Chancen. Aber ich denke nicht, dass es reicht, auch auf Nijmegen zu kommen. Ich glaube, Nijmegen kann sich dann quasi nur selbst schlagen. Sie haben jetzt die Match-Bälle gegen diese beiden Vereine aus dem Mittelfeld, wenn die da vielleicht ein bisschen weniger Risiko gehen. Das haben sie jetzt in den letzten Wochen auch schon gemacht. Das zahlt jetzt nicht ganz immer aus gegen Tester. Gegen Tester sah es so ein bisschen so aus, da hatte der Motto, naja, wir gehen jetzt hier vielleicht nicht unbedingt auf Sieg. Und dann nehmen wir den Punkt gerne mit. Dann haben wir 56 Punkte. Also ich glaube, diese Risikobereitschaft, wie sie ausgezeichnet hatte in Nijmegen, die geht jetzt, weil jetzt wirklich was Greifbares da ist, was sie ja wirklich gewinnen können. geht so ein bisschen abhanden, habe ich das Gefühl. Ja, müssen wir gucken, ob dieser etwas defensiverer Ansatz aus den letzten Spielen sie wirklich trägt. Aber ich gehe schon davon aus. Und bei Twente auf Platz 5, die haben, glaube ich, echt auch nur außenseite der Chancen. Das große Problem von Twente ist letztendlich, dass sie am letzten Spieltag gegen Eindhoven ran müssen. Da ist dann eine Siegschance dann doch sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich. Das heißt, eigentlich müssen sie gegen Sparta, gegen die jetzt jetzt auch kommende Woche, diese Woche, müssen sie eigentlich gewinnen. Und dann müssen hoffen, dass Neue Mikro und Amt und Freilichs eben so ein bisschen fehlen lassen. Aber für Sparta gibt es ja auch noch was. Weil die sind auf Platz 9. Also die wollen ja auch dann in die Playoffs um die UCL. Also auch eine Folge von diesem Bläser-Thema. Das sind eben auch der 9. am letzten Spieltag. Für die geht es halt noch richtig was. Die sind ein Punkt vor 10. Also die wollen auch nicht wieder runterfallen.
Das war doch ein super System. Keine goldenen Analysen. Aber gut, da kann man jetzt viel drüber diskutieren. Aber ja, wir werden es verfolgen. Nijmegen auf jeden Fall. Wir haben es ja im Februar schon mal besprochen. Aber da lohnt einen im Blick drauf. Ich würde sie ja ganz gerne mal auch in einem Europapokal dann genauer unter die Lupe nehmen können. Und es ist ja generell gerade die Zeit der Restprogrammübersichten, die man sich immer aufmachen muss. Und dasselbe habe ich jetzt getan. Ich habe es ehrlich gesagt offengelassen in der Liga. Denn da ging es ja auch noch um den Abstieg, Jakob. Und da gibt es direkte Duelle. Zeichne uns mal das Bild, das wir vor Augen haben müssen und sag uns, was uns erwartet.
Genau, wir klären erst einmal zum Start, was schon entschieden ist. Ich glaube, das ist der leichteste Weg. Ich hatte es vorhin schon kurz gesagt. MES ist abgestiegen. Das war ja auch schon seit dem Herbst eigentlich absehbar. Da hatte ich das ja schon prognostiziert, dass das wahrscheinlich nichts wird. Die werden damit jetzt also weiterhin zum Jojo-Club springen, immer so hin und her zwischen den beiden Ligen, waren jetzt auch letztendlich völlig chancenlos. Der zweite Absteiger ist vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt überraschend, weil es sich so ein bisschen angedeutet hat, aber es ist aufgrund der Größe des Vereins. Es steht jetzt noch nicht hundertprozentig fest, aber wenn Nantes jetzt am Freitag gegen Lens nicht gewinnt, sind sie auch unten und das ist natürlich schon eine deutlich größere Geschichte, weil das ja einer der schon historischen Schwergewichte auch in Frankreich ist. Das ist jetzt in den letzten Jahrzehnten waren sie nicht mehr so häufig oben mit dabei, aber sie halten ja auch weiterhin zum Beispiel den Rekord für die einzige ungeschlagene Saison, die es jemals gab in der höchsten französischen Spielklasse und haben ja auch die eine oder andere Meisterschaft schon gewonnen. Also das wäre schon durchaus ein Verlust, auch wenn das jetzt so ein ja so ein bisschen entwickelter Niedergang auf jeden Fall war, vielleicht ein bisschen so mit den Abstiegen von Werder und dem HSV auch zu vergleichen gewesen, wenn man einen Bundesliga-Vergleich ziehen will. Da ging es also auch rapide, also so stetig bergab. Und dann ist noch Le Havre theoretisch dran beteiligt. Die sind auf Platz 14 momentan, haben 5 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz 16. Dazwischen steht auch noch NHTSA. Ich denke nicht, dass Le Havre noch mal reinrutscht. Die Punkten auch weiterhin sehr konstant, haben schon 14-mal unentschieden gespielt in dieser Saison. Also sind wirklich ein wahnsinnig schwer zu schlagen, das Team. Das ist echt beeindruckend. Da hatten wir, glaube ich, auch irgendwann in dieser Saison schon mal drüber geredet. Die spielen jetzt noch gegen Marseille und Lorient an den letzten beiden Spieltagen. Also ich glaube, da wird so ein Punkt noch mal runterfallen. Und das müsste dann eigentlich schon reichen, um den Klassenerhalt zu schaffen. Und richtig spannend ist es auf den Plätzen 15 und 16. Es gibt in Frankreich ja auch, genau wie in Deutschland, die Relegation. Und momentan steht auf Platz 16 Aji Auxerre mit 28 Punkten. Und da drüber auf Platz 15 steht Aujse Nitsa mit 31 Punkten. Also drei Punkte Unterschied. Aber das Besondere ist, wie du ja gerade schon so angedeutet hattest, dass die jetzt am 33. Spieltag im direkten Duell aufeinander treffen. Und Auxerre hat auch das bessere Torverhältnis mit neun Punkten Toren Vorsprung. Also da wird sich wahrscheinlich auch nichts mehr dran ändern. Das heißt, mit einem Sieg könnte Auxerre auch vorbei ziehen an Nitsa. Zumindest am 33. Spieltag. Denn am 34. Spieltag spielt Nitsa dann gegen MES, also die schon abgestiegenen. Wo dann natürlich die Frage ist, gewinnen sie da nicht vielleicht? Oder will MES nochmal ein letztes Hurra starten? Und Auxerre spielt gegen Lille, also auch ein Team von ganz oben, für die es noch um vieles geht. Das heißt, für Nitsa wäre jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Niederlage direkt der Gang in die Relegation. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem ein Spiel von sehr, sehr hoher Bedeutung jetzt am 33. Spieltag. Und was so ein bisschen kurios ist, ist, dass beide Teams jetzt gar nicht in so richtig schlechter Form sind, aber trotzdem nicht so richtig von der Stelle kommen. Also Nitsa zum Beispiel ist seit fünf Spielen ungeschlagen, hat allerdings auch viermal unentschieden gespielt und hat nur eins davon gewonnen. Da ist mit Eli Wahi auch ein Bekannter aus der Bundesliga, der ja von Frankfurt aus geliehen ist, jetzt fünf Tore und einen Assist in zwölf Spielen geliefert hat seit seiner Ankunft, also schon ganz gut ist. Für Nitsa gilt aber auch, dass es natürlich eine Katastrophe ist, dass sie da unten drin stehen. Und wenn es tatsächlich in die Relegation oder gar in die 2. Liga gehen sollte, wäre das auch ein echter Betriebsunfall. Da ist ja auch INEOS als Besitzergruppe dahinterstehend, die aber Nitsa auch seit Jahren schon vernachlässigen. Jim Redcliffe hat ja auch gesagt, dass ihn das eigentlich überhaupt nicht interessiert, was in Nitsa passiert und ja, dass ihm das auch relativ egal sei. Also sieht man auch mal wieder, wie schön das ist, wenn man das kleinere Licht im Multiclub-Ownership-Konstrukt ist. Und wir hatten ja auch in dieser Saison schon mal über die ganzen Unruhen gesprochen. Also gab ja auch Angriffe auf die Mannschaft, auch ein Fanboykott, der lange andauert. Und demgegenüber steht dann halt, dass sie auch noch im Pokalfinale stehen. Und wenn sie tatsächlich in die Relegation kommen, könnte es das zweite Mal in Folge einen Pokalfinalisten geben, der dann auch in der Relegation spielt. Das war in der letzten Saison mit Stadtrance auch der Fall. Diesmal müssten dann die Relegationsspiele sogar verschoben werden, weil das sonst mit dem Pokalfinale terminlich nicht aufgehen würde. Also da hängt auch noch relativ viel dran. Und für Nizza ist natürlich dann auch so ein bisschen die Frage, was priorisiert man jetzt? Reims hat das in der letzten Saison auch nicht gut geschafft. Die sind dann in der Relegation ja runtergegangen und haben das Pokalfinale verloren. Also so ein bisschen das Schlechteste aus beiden Welten bekommen. Und Auxerre hatten wir ja auch schon mal drüber gesprochen, dass sie krass unterperformen und da von den Leistungen her eigentlich gar nicht unbedingt stehen müssten. Und das ist auch weiterhin der Fall. Die hätten nach Expected Points 11 oder 12 Punkte mehr holen sollen eigentlich, als sie jetzt momentan haben, hätten dann also gar nichts zu tun eigentlich mit dem Abstieg. Und da ist halt vor allem die Offensive für verantwortlich, die jetzt aber in den letzten Spielen zumindest wieder ein bisschen besser funktioniert. Man hat jetzt beispielsweise 3-1 gegen Angers gewonnen, davor immerhin zwei Tore gegen Lyon geschossen, wengleich man da zwei, drei verloren hat. Davor zwei zu zwei gegen Monaco gespielt. Und generell ist der Trend bei OXR eigentlich auch sehr positiv. Es stellt sich aber jetzt halt so ein bisschen die Frage angesichts des Restprogramms, ob ihnen vielleicht so ein bisschen die Spiele ausgehen und der positive Trend ein bisschen zu spät kam. Denn seit Ende Januar haben sie in 13 Spielen auch nur drei Niederlagen kassiert, was ja überhaupt keine Bilanz eines Absteigers ist. Eigentlich allerdings halt auch nur drei Spiele gewonnen und halt auch wieder diese sieben Unentschieden. Also so ein Ding, was irgendwie alle Teams im Keller ein bisschen ja, plagt, dass sie es einfach nicht schaffen, ein Unentschieden mal in einen Sieg zu verwandeln. Die große Hoffnung bei Oxair liegt auf Lassin Sinayoko, dem Stürmer, der jetzt vier Scorer in den letzten fünf Spielen gesammelt hat, der auch so die zentrale Figur bei Oxair ist. Also ein ja durchaus wichtiger Angreifer für sie. Und ja, schauen wir erst mal, wie es jetzt am 33. Spieltag läuft. Ich bin da auf jeden Fall extrem gespannt, wie das direkte Duell dann ausgeht.
Aber wirklich, also am Sonntag wird das stattfinden, diese Partie um 21 Uhr, wenn ich es richtig sehe. Also auch Top-Spiel quasi dieses Tages dann.
Ja, da sind aber acht Partien gleichzeitig schon.
Die sind doch nicht so schlau wie die Bundesliga und haben es nicht gesplittet.
Genau, nur Lens gegen Nantes, Freitags. Und dann sind alle anderen acht Spiele schon um 21 Uhr. Also ist ja aus Wettbewerbsgründen auch durchaus angenehm, dass die alle parallel sind.
Also wüsste ich jetzt, kann ich jetzt leider gerade gar keinen Bundesliga-Vergleich zu ziehen. Gibt es, finde ich, hier keine Thematik. Aber gut. Lassen wir das. Also das ist die Situation in der Liga. Und dann müssen wir aber, Chris, auch nochmal über die Premier League sprechen. Denn wir haben jetzt mit Newcast begonnen. Es gibt aber natürlich zumindest ganz kurz, müssen wir schon auch noch ein Update aus dem Meisterschaftskampf liefern. Da lag City bei Everton schon zurück, ist am Ende dann in der 97. Minute, glaube ich, noch auf ein 3 zu 3 gekommen. Wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, hat danach der Torschütze den Finger auf die Lippen gelegt und hat gesagt, beruhigt euch alle mal. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut er Tabellen lesen kann. Denn de facto sollte Arsenal jetzt die verbleibenden drei Spiele noch gewinnen, dann ist Arsenal Meister. Also was hat sich da verändert?
Ja, einiges. Vor zwei Wochen schien es noch so, als würde Arsenal alles verspielen und diesen Bottler-Narrativ ja auch wirklich Futter geben. Gegen den Zweitligist ist der Pokal ausgeschieden, der Liga-Pokalfinale verloren, direkt das Duell gegen City verloren. Und jetzt, wie du sagst, zwei Wochen später, hat man den Vorteil im Titelrennen. Und was man auch so ein bisschen gespürt hat, kurioserweise seit dem City-Spiel, seit dieser Niederlage, ist auch so die ganze Stimmung um den Verein und die Mannschaft deutlich besser geworden. Das liegt vor allem daran– ich habe es eingangs schon gesagt– man hatte die ganze Saison wirklich nicht die gesamte Offensive zur Verfügung. Und jetzt gegen City ging es wieder da in die richtige Richtung, dass man offensiver gespielt hat. Und jetzt gegen Fulham am Wochenende beim 3 zu 0 war das wirklich wahrscheinlich die beste Offensivleistung der Saison. Und da sieht man, wenn offensiven Spieler zur Verfügung stehen oder die besten, dann spielt man auch gut im Fußball. Saka in seiner alten Form, Tor- und Assistener der ersten Halbzeit. Und eh sehr stark gespielt. Und eine Personalie, an dem du den Aufschwung bei Arsenal auch wieder ein bisschen ausmachen kannst, ist Miles Louis Kelly. 19 Jahre alt, letzte Saison absolute Durchbruchssaison als Linksverteidiger gespielt. Diese Saison gar nicht zum Zug gekommen. Seine eigentliche Position ist auf der 6 bzw. auf der 8. Und ich fand es schon bezeichnend, dass Arteta jetzt in dieser sensiblen Phase der Saison ihn plötzlich im Mittelfeld eingesetzt hat erstmalig. Auch in Champions League Halbfinale-Rückspiel, in seinem zweiten Profi-Spiel als Mittelfeldspieler überhaupt. Von Anfang an. Und in beiden Spielen wirklich absolut überzeugt. Und es zeigt auch so ein bisschen, dass Arteta auch erkannt hat, dieses Pragmatische, mit dem man am Anfang gespielt hat, das wird nicht funktionieren, dieses Verwalten. Man muss stattdessen wieder der Aggressor sein. Und Louis Kelly unterstreicht das ein bisschen, weil er ein unfassbar progressiver Spielertyp ist. Er sucht immer den Pass nach vorne, immer das Dribbling, trotz seines jungen Alters. Und seitdem sieht man auch an den Passing-Maps und an den Grundpositionen im Spiel, dass alles viel, viel offensiver geworden ist. Und deswegen habe ich vorhin auch so ein bisschen die Atletico-Spiele verteidigt, weil ich auch weiß, wie die Spiele vorher aussahen in Sachen Ballprogression und so weiter. Und das sieht schon alles deutlich besser aus. Und man merkt, das ist auch so ein bisschen eigentlich die DNA dieser Mannschaft, offensiv zu spielen. Das ist ja eher eine Ausnahmesaison. Und letzte Saison auch ein bisschen wegen Verletzungen. Aber man merkt, jetzt kommt man so ein bisschen back to the roots. Und schon ist wieder dieses Selbstvertrauen da, das Selbstverständnis da. Und man merkt, ausgerechnet auf den letzten Metern kriegt Arsenal wieder Form und vor allem auch seine vierten Spieler zurück. Und dementsprechend hat man jetzt durchaus den Vorteil im Titelkampf. West Ham ist jetzt so das schwierigste Spiel der Verbleibenden am Sonntag auswärts. Wenn Arsenal da gewinnt, denke ich, ist es ziemlich wahrscheinlich, dass man den Titel holen wird. Auch weil City noch zwei schwere Spiele mit Brentford und Bormelf hat. Und zu City muss man sagen, man redet die ganze Zeit von diesem Bottler-Narrativ bei Arsenal. Aber ziemlich interessant finde ich, ist, dass City dieses Kalenderjahr die meisten Punkte nach Führung verloren hat. Das widerspricht dem Ganzen so ein bisschen. Und ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Faktor für mich ist auch, man sagt immer, City war in diesem Titelkampf schon so oft. Aber diese Größen der letzten Jahre, ein De Bruyne, ein jetzt auch ein Rotri, der jetzt angeschlagen ist, die fehlen gerade so ein bisschen. Und man hat zwar im Winter mit Gehi und Semenyo zwei absolute Unterschiedsspieler verpflichtet. Und ohne sie wäre man gar nicht erst wieder da drangekommen. Aber man merkt auch, dass diese beiden Spieler noch nie in so einer Situation waren. Und es war ja Gehi, der am Montag gegen Everton diesen katastrophalen Aussetzer hatte, der bei diesem zu kurz geratenen Rückpass spielt. Bis dahin hat der Yaseedi alles im Griff. Und dann ist das Spiel gekippt. Dann hattest du 13 unerklärliche Minuten, wo du komplett von der Rolle warst. Und man hat vor allem Gehi den Nerven angemerkt. Und das ist auch ein ganz interessanter Faktor jetzt auf den letzten Metern. Wäre jetzt tatsächlich unabhängig, wenn irgendwelche Narrativen mental stärker auch durch diese Wochen kommt.
Also total interessant. Werden wir natürlich mitverfolgen, wie es in der Premier League noch weiter läuft. Wir blicken noch ein letztes Mal nach Spanien. Also ein letztes Mal natürlich nur für diese Sendung. Ich habe es schon vorhin einmal kurz angedeutet, Nils, als ich Espanol habe erwähnt in einem Nebensatz. Es war, glaube ich, bei den Flanken, die geschlagen wurden. Dementsprechend wundert es mich nicht, dass es nicht läuft.
Da ist ein Edo Exposito noch vorne mit dabei. Auch in der Liga die zweitmeisten Key-Pässe. Also nur ein Lamine Jamal hat mehr. Ja, das lief in der Hinrunde noch. Ich glaube, da hatte ich im Dezember in einer Folge drüber geredet, mit vermeintlich einfachen Fußballen. Kike Garcia vorne geschickt werden, einen einnicken. Das hat da noch gut geklappt. Aber ja, damals war man noch auf Platz 5. Und seit Weihnachten hat man 17 Spiele bestritten und nicht ein einziges mehr gewonnen. Das ist ein 5-unentschiedenen Zeitraum. Das ist ein La Liga-Negativrekord zum Jahresstart, so viele Spiele sieglos zu sein. Und deswegen befindet sich jetzt Espanyol doch noch mit dem Abstiegskampf. 3 Punkte vor Alaves, die da der erste Abstiegsplatz sind. Das ist ja so ein bisschen... Man zehrt noch vom Kredit der Hinrunde, als man wie gesagt 5. war, aber auf einmal da ist man irgendwie eingestürzt, weil wie gesagt überschaubarer Fußball. Man hat auch hier und da Pech. Ich glaube, von den XG-Werten hat man die drittgrößte Differenz. Man sollte eigentlich 12 Tore mehr haben, laut XG-Zahlen, aber irgendwie ist dann dieser Flankenfußball dann doch nicht nachhaltig genug oder jetzt in der Rückrunde einfach auch entschlüsselt und die Teams wissen jetzt, okay, die versuchen A und B und kommt nicht viel anderes.
Ja gut, ich meine, das mit den Flanken ist natürlich von mir auch so ein bisschen polemisch formuliert gewesen. Das ist interessant, weil von den Expected Points, zumindest nach Enderstat, liegt man genau da, wo man sein sollte. Da hätte man 39,6, also vielleicht gerundet dann noch einen mehr als die 39, die man aktuell hat. Ist es jetzt dann die normale Regression zur Mitte, die man hat, oder ist es eine Regression über die Mitte hinaus? Also man steht jetzt gerade ein bisschen schlechter da, als man eigentlich da sein sollte. So ein bisschen Klangsitz gerade?
Ja, ich glaube, Espanyol gehört schon tendenziell eher so ins untere Drittel, ist auch eine absolute Fahrstuhlmannschaft. Ich glaube jetzt vier Jahre in Folge immer auf oder abgestiegen auf und abgestiegen.
Eine Jojo-Mannschaft, wie man es offenbar in Frankreich nennt. Das habe ich mir gleich gemerkt, Jakob, das finde ich sehr, sehr schön. Das klingt ein bisschen fröhlicher als so ein Fahrstuhl, ehrlich gesagt.
Klingt schöner. Ja, also von der Hinrunde, das war einfach eher ein Überperforming. Jetzt steht man da, hat natürlich auch Malpech. Aber trotzdem, man hält noch an Trainer Manolo Fest, dem ehemaligen Busfahrer. Also das ist ja auch irgendwie eine besondere Geschichte bei ihm. Aber ja, wer weiß, vier Spieltage noch, ob es da nicht doch noch irgendwie einen Panikwechsel gibt, weil irgendwie andere Teams punkten ja. Mallorca unter dem Ikelis ist gut dabei. Auch allerwissen Levante haben zuletzt einige Punkte eingefahren. Deswegen ist jetzt auch noch mal Sevilla mit dem entwickelten Niedergang auch noch mit unten drin im Abstiegskampf. Aber Espanyol eben auch noch reingerutscht, weil wie gesagt auch ein Edo Exposito da nicht mehr so funktioniert oder ein Kikigasier. Carlos Romero wird eh dann gehen. Der ist nur ausgeliehen, also top Außenverteidiger. Von dem her ist da jetzt Zukunftsprognose bei Espanyol sowieso auch schwierig. Und ja, wenn der letzte Sieg einfach vor Weihnachten noch war, ist ja eine Weile her.
Das ist wohl wahr. Ja, dann schauen wir mal, ob der Bus von Manolo die Endhaltestelle erreicht oder ob er noch eine neue Runde drehen darf in der nächsten Saison. Christian, wir schauen nochmal in die Serie A. Da möchtest du uns einen Trainer andrehen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Andrehen, ja, genau, absolut. Ja, wir schauen kurz auf Sao Paulo. Aufsteiger. Ich habe jetzt nicht die anderen Ligen im Blick, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, einer der erfolgreichsten Aufsteiger dieser Saison. Die sind noch im Rennen um Platz 8 kurz vor Schluss, also haben die Möglichkeit, noch achter zu werden. Ich gehe mal davon aus, bei all den Kollegen hier wird es jetzt nicht viele Aufsteiger geben, die in solchen Sphären unterwegs sind. Haben jetzt Milan am Wochenende geschlagen. Ah, Jakob meldet sich schon. Komm, Jakob, auf geht's.
Ich hätte Lurion auf neunem angeboten.
Ja, sehr gut. Dann haben wir also das Duell Lurion gegen Sao Paulo. Sehr schön, gefällt mir. Aus der Distanz. Nee, haben jetzt am Wochenende Milan geschlagen, haben vor zwei Wochen Cormo geschlagen, haben Atalanta zweimal in dieser Saison geschlagen, haben gegen Juve gepunktet.
Also, Sao Paulo spielt eine richtig gute Saison. Hatten wir auch schon mal kurz, ist kein typischer Aufsteiger, weil da ist schon viel Qualität auch aus der 2. Liga mit hochgegangen, mit Berardi, mit Lorientet, mit Pinamonte. Also, das war eigentlich ein Kader, der zu gut für die 2. Liga ist, aber trotzdem machen sie es sehr gut. Und ja, da landen wir beim Trainer und das ist Fabio Grosso. Der sagt wahrscheinlich in Deutschland noch dem einen oder anderen was. Da gab es mal eine Geschichte, als er noch Spieler war, genau. Und es gibt ja auch seine Trainergeschichte, ganz spannend. Da weiß Jakob logischerweise auch. Der war bei Lyon. Es war ein sehr kurzer Abstecher. Er hat sich dann drei Vierteljahr Pause genommen, ist an der Zeit 2.24 bei Saas-Waller und hat sich da wirklich jetzt langsam, ganz langsam, richtig stabilisiert, nach oben gearbeitet. Saas-Waller hat mir ja auch schon mal sehr gut gearbeitet. Ich glaube, es ist ein gutes Ambiente, für Tränen oder so, weil sehr wenig Druck da ist, Presse, ganz ruhig, kleiner Ort. Also da kannst du in Ruhe arbeiten. Und das hat Grosso gemacht und jetzt ist er in Italien bei sehr vielen, also er hat noch ein Jahr Vertrag bei Sassuolo, aber es deutet einiges darauf hin, dass er jetzt den nächsten Schritt macht. Und es gibt einige Kandidaten, er ist bei der Fiorentina im Gespräch, er ist bei Bologna im Gespräch, er ist bei Lazio im Gespräch. Also er hat sich wirklich sehr auf sich aufmerksam gemacht, spielt ein ansehnliches 4-3-3, gut ausbalanciert, sehr zurückhaltender Typ, Grosso, obwohl er ja schon in seiner Karriere ein bisschen was vorzuweisen hat, er als Spieler überhaupt nicht einer, der das Rampenlicht sucht, sehr zurückhaltend, angenehm auch so auf Pressekonferenzen. Er ist jetzt diesen Umweg über Sassuolo auch in die 2. Liga mitgegangen, gegangen und das scheint seiner Entwicklung als Trainer sehr gut getan zu haben und deswegen, ich glaube, die Chancen stehen gut, dass er jetzt so den nächsten Schritt macht, sich bei einem doch etwas ambitionierteren, vom Namen her größeren Club dann auch zu beweisen. Und er ist auf jeden Fall eine heiße Traineraktie in der Serie A.
In der 2. Liga noch 4-2-3-1 gespielt, dann 3-5 in Palermo verloren.
Oh, in Palermo, sehr schön.
Dann hat er umgestellt auf 4-3-3. Seine Konsequenz daraus war, okay, alles klar, 1-6er weg. Das ist natürlich jetzt nur Mathematik und sehr, sehr einfach. Aber ja, Fabio Grosso, wunderbar, sehr schön. Schauen wir doch, wie es für ihn bei Sassuolo weitergeht. Daniel, was haben wir noch in der Eredivise?
Wir haben eventuell auch irgendwann einen neuen Karriere-Schritt. Und zwar vielleicht von Jadon Owuse Oduro. Das ist der Torwart von Alkmaar. Der ist erst 21, ist aber schon die Nummer eins und Stammspieler mit echt guter Leistung. Er war jetzt in dieser Saison ein paar Mal verletzt, deswegen hat er jetzt von den zwei, drei Spielen 21 nur gemacht. Hat aber auch sechsmal zu Null gespielt. Also der Junge kannte wirklich schon was. Und er hatte jetzt ein denkwürdiges Spiel am vergangenen Wochenende, nämlich gegen Entschütter, also die, die ja noch irgendwie auch die Zerters haben wollen. Lief eigentlich alles gut für Alkmaar gegen Arsenal in Führung. Dann gab es aber zwei Patzer von Uruso Uru, und zwar einmal Eigentor und dann auch nochmal ein Patzer bei dem 2-1 von Twente. Und es sah schon so aus, als twente dann mit ihrem eher defensiven Ansatz, den sie jetzt auch im Missverfolgen, da drei Punkte holen kann. Aber es gab am Ende noch eine Ecke, 90 plus 5. Er war mit nach vorne und hat nicht den Trübling gemacht. Er hat jetzt nicht selbst getroffen, aber er kam an den Ball, hat ihn immerhin vorgelegt für Quote Miners, der mit einem schönen Tanzschuss von außerhalb des Strafraums zum 2-2, zum viel umjubelten 2-2 dann einschenken konnte. Und hat mich persönlich sehr für ihn gefreut. Und ich glaube auch, dass Uzo Uduro, der spielt auch UU als Zusammenarbeit von den Nierlanden, U21 hat einen Einsatz jetzt schon gehabt. Ich glaube, dass der eigentlich auch in den nächsten Jahren zum größeren Verein entweder in der Halte Nierhande wechselt oder die sehen eigentlich auch schon in eine größere Liga in Europa wechseln. Hat das Vertrag aber vor kurzem verlängert. Also er ist eigentlich recht sesshaft und sehr, sehr eigmar gebunden auch. Aber bei den Leistungen, die er bringt, ist es eigentlich eine Frage der Zeit, bis er auch mal einen größeren Verein spielt.
Fantastisch.
Das war es auch schon. Eine kleine Happy End gerichtet als Rauschmeister.
Stark. Christian hatte sich kurz gemeldet bei der Vorlage, ich weiß nicht.
Nein, ich wollte noch ganz kurz, sorry. Coop Miners, gibt es da familiären Bezug?
Ja, es müsste der guter sein. Ich liefe auf jeden Fall noch nach, ich hook mir kurz.
Geil ist er wie in der Bundespressekonferenz jetzt. Aber gut.
Aber nicht unter drei.
Ja, und ich meine, immerhin antwortest du auf meine Fragen. Also ganz so ist es dann doch noch nicht. Dann bin ich gespannt, was uns Jakob noch mitgebracht hat.
Ich habe auch einen erfolgreichen Trainer noch mitgebracht. Jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Trainer-Talent wie Fabio Grosso, aber ein Trainer, der zumindest in Frankreich sowieso schon durchaus sich auch einen Namen gemacht hatte, mit Antoine Comboire. Der hat nämlich zum 1. Mai– nee, 1. März hatte er Paris FC übernommen, also da den zweiten Aufsteiger, der jetzt tatsächlich in der Terwelle ganz gut dasteht und theoretisch sogar auch noch bis auf Platz 8 klettern könnte. Als er sie übernommen hat, war Paris allerdings auf Platz 15. Und ich meine, wir hatten über die ja auch mal gesprochen, dass es eine extrem enttäuschende Saison ist, weil sie ja auch nicht so der typische Aufsteiger sind, sehr, sehr viel Geld in die Hand genommen haben. Und ja auch einer der wenigen Vereine in Frankreich sind, die wirklich Geld investieren können. Jetzt unter Combo Arré sieht man das auch viel, viel mehr. Der hat wirklich eine ganz fantastische Bilanz, hat jetzt aus neun Spielen fünf Siege, drei Unentschieden und nur eine einzige Niederlage. Und die war auch noch sehr unglücklich gegen Lille. Da haben sie auch noch ein Elber verschossen, also ein Punkteschnitt von 2,0. Also damit würde man in einer ganzen Saison dann locker um Europa mitspielen auf jeden Fall. Beziehungsweise hätte sich jetzt sogar in dieser Saison zum Beispiel auch schon fast fix für die Champions League qualifiziert. Also das ist dann ein ganz, ganz anderer Kurs im Vergleich zu dem, den Paris vorher gefahren ist. Und das resultiert jetzt auch darin, dass Combo Arré, der eigentlich in Frankreich jetzt gerade so in den letzten Jahren immer eher als Feuerwehrmann galt, mit 62 jetzt auch ja nicht uralt, aber schon dann doch eher gehobenen Traineralter ist und nicht mehr zumindest so ein junger Trainer ist, wie zum Beispiel auch Stephane Gilly, der in Paris FC vorher hatte, der so ein bisschen eher als Trainer für die Zukunft galt. Und bei Combo Arré dachte man eher, das wäre jetzt eine Lösung, um sie vor dem Abstieg zu retten. Jetzt läuft es aber so gut, dass alles darauf hindeutet, dass er auch dann die nächste Saison noch mal bekommt. Und vielleicht ist das ja auch genau die richtige Mischung bei Paris FC, die finanzielle Kraft, also dass man wirklich eigentlich einen super guten Kader zusammenstellen kann mit guten Mitteln. Und dann aber einem eher erfahreneren Trainer, der weiß, worauf es in der Liga auch ankommt, der vor allem auch auf eine solide Defensive setzt. Also sieben Gegentore jetzt in seinen neuen Spielen sind dann auch eine echt gute Bilanz. Da ist Kevin Trapp auch einer der Schlüsselfaktoren. Er war ja lange Zeit gar nicht Stammkeeper, ist aber jetzt seit längerer Zeit schon im Tor und gibt da der Abwehr auf jeden Fall viel, viel Stabilität. Und ja, so ist es dann Combo Arré eben gelungen, diese natürlich auch für den Abstieg völlig überqualifizierte Mannschaft zu stabilisieren, aber halt auch nicht nur defensiv Beton anzurühren, sondern gerade jetzt in den letzten Spielen läuft es halt auch offensiv gut. Und da sind dann auch ein paar interessante Namen dabei. Zum Beispiel kam im Winter Marshal Munezzi, ein zentraler Mittelfeldspieler von Wolverhampton. Der hat jetzt schon vier Tore gemacht als von der sechster Position, also auch nicht so schlecht. Seit am letzten Wochenende mit Rudi Matondo, eins der wenigen französischen großen Talente, seine ersten beiden Tore in der Liga erzielt. Auch ein zentraler Mittelfeldspieler hat einen Doppelpack geschnürt. Das ist auf jeden Fall einer, auf den man auch nochmal ein Auge haben konnte. Und sogar Giro Immobile im Sturm hat letztens auch mal getroffen. Wurde, meine ich sogar, zum Spieler ab des Monats April nur von Paris FC, also nicht ganz ligaübergreifend, aber zumindest des Vereins gewählt. Also hat da dann jetzt auch, nachdem es bei ihm auch erst gar nicht lief nach seinem Transfer, jetzt zumindest nochmal seinen Beitrag geleistet. Also, ja, und da könnte es jetzt theoretisch sogar, wie gesagt, noch bis auf Platz 8 nach oben gehen. Und ich bin dann gerade auch in Bezug auf die nächste Saison gespannt, weil Paris FC von den Möglichkeiten und auch den eigenen Ansprüchen her eigentlich wahrscheinlich sogar um Europa mitspielen sollte. Ja, schon.
Genau, weil da eben ein Brausehersteller und noch anderes Geld dahinter steckt. Chris, du hattest dich schon gemeldet, bevor Ciro Immobile genannt wurde.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt. Ich wollte nur ganz kurz den italienischen Bezug jetzt Ciro Immobile, weil da gibt es einiges. Das ist die Vergangenheit, aber sie haben mit Colioscio und mit Coppola auch zwei ganz spannende junge Italiener, weil man das auch gerade Coppola von Brighton ausgeliehen hat. Der gibt der Defensiv ja auch definitiv Stabilität, weil bei der U21 auch herausragend. Das tut dem richtig gut, dass der jetzt einfach Spielpraxis kriegt. Und Colioscio, ein ganz spannender Mann, mit der wichtigsten Offensive der italienischen U21. Also der kommt da auch gut ins Rollen. Also das sind auch einige junge Italiener, die jetzt diesen Paris FC Weg gehen und der ihn auch sehr gut tut.
Sehr schön.
Ja, beide auch ganz wichtig. Also Coppola zum Beispiel hat auch mit Otavio ein eigentlicher teuren Innenverteidiger, der von Porto gekommen war vor der Saison, verdrängt. Und ist da dann jetzt auch Teil dieses Abwehrgerüstes mit Kevin Trapp.
Stark, sehr gut. Haben wir noch hier ein paar junge Spieler, auf die man mal ein Auge werfen kann. Das ausgerechnet im Ligue 1-Segment. Wer hätte damit gerechnet? So, dann wirft uns jetzt Chris raus und zwar mit einer Hard-C-Debatte. Geht es da um Franziska Kett gegen Salma Parru-Luello oder worüber wird da diskutiert, Chris?
Nein, es geht um Tolu Arokodare's Geheimwaffe, der Stimmer von Wolverhampton. Der hat nämlich ziemlich lange Dreadlocks und hat jetzt am Wochenende bereits zum zweiten Mal seinen Gegner dazu verleitet, daran zu ziehen und dadurch einen Platzverweis mit sich gebracht. Also zweimal gegen ihn. Haare ziehen rot in dieser Saison. Es gab auch noch einen weiteren Fall diese Saison, Alessandro Martinez gegen Karl-Bert Lewin. Und das hat in der Family League jetzt wieder so eine kleine Debatte ausgelöst, ob das denn wirklich rot ist. Und da gibt es eigentlich eine ganz klare Antwort zu, die PGMOL, also die Schiedsrichterorganisation in England, hat wiederholt auch in dieser Saison in ihrer Guidance klargemacht, das ist eine Tätigkeit, das ist rot. Und das führt auch zu einer Dreispielesperre. Das will nicht jeder Trainer so wirklich akzeptieren. Ich fand aber auch Sunderlands Regie Le Brie, also der Trainer, seine Aussagen nach dem Spiel dazu ganz witzig, hat nämlich ein bisschen ein Problem damit. Er hat gesagt, wenn du gegen Stürmer mit langen Haaren spielst, hast du jetzt ein Problem, weil man kann sie nicht mehr verteidigen. Das fand ich jetzt etwas, sich etwas zu einfach gemacht. Denn man muss ja nicht unbedingt an den Hahn ziehen. Aber es gab jetzt so ein bisschen ein Hin und Her. Ich glaube, beim Frauenfußball war das auch zuletzt eine Debatte, weil es nicht immer geahndet wurde. Aber eigentlich, regletechnisch, sollte das immer Rot mit sich bringen.
Genau, es gab eine Halbfinale zwischen Chelsea und Arsenal. Da gab es ein klares Haareziehen, was sowohl die Schiedsrichterin auf dem Feld nicht gesehen hat, was auch Katarzyna Rafalski als Video-Assistant Referee nicht zum Eingreifen würdig befand. Das wäre eine klare rote Karte gewesen. Und dann gab es im anderen Halbfinale– ne, Entschuldigung, das war das Viertelfinale, das andere Spiel– und im Halbfinale zwischen Bayern und Barca hat eben Franziska Kett, sagen wir mal, para duello, an den Haaren gezogen, aber auf leicht über Hüfte. Und das hat eben dann der FC Bayern oder Vertreterinnen des FC Bayern zum Anlass genommen, eben auch eine Debatte loszutreten. Ob das eine rote Karte sein kann, wenn die Haare doch so lang sind. Sie hätte ja nur am Trikot ziehen wollen. Was mich an dieser Debatte da sehr gestört hat, ich meine, das habe ich in den entsprechenden Sendungen im Rasenfunk, haben wir das auch besprochen, wenn euch das interessiert. Das war die Bundesliga-Frauenspieltagssendung, an dem Spieltag, an dem das Spiel war. Könnt ihr noch mal reinhören, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Was mich da gestört hat, war, dass die betroffenen Spielerinnen da überhaupt nicht zur Sprache kamen, sondern es waren halt immer quasi andere, die gesagt haben, müssten die nicht eigentlich ihre Haare anders haben. Sagt denn Aro Kodare was zu seinem Fall?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen. Nicht bewusst zumindest.
Und das ist nämlich dann, finde ich, das Problem. Man kann ja Diskussionen führen, aber halt indem man die Betroffenen, also die sollten ja mit zuerst befragt werden, plus es hat halt dann auch einen rassistischen Anklang, auch wenn es nicht so gemeint ist, aber Dreadlocks zum Beispiel haben ja auch eine kulturelle Geschichte. Und es kann sein, dass du ganz zufällig Dreadlocks hast, es kann aber auch eben ganz andere Gründe haben, als in Anführungszeichen nur eine Frisur zu sein. Deswegen habe ich da so ein bisschen so ein Unwohlsein, wenn eben die eigentlich Betroffenen davon nicht zu Wort kommen. Und Jakob hat sich auch schon gemeldet.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich auch nur das nochmal ansprechen, also dass es historisch halt auch eine gewisse Bedeutung hat, gerade was das Haareziehen bei schwarzen Menschen angeht. Und generell ja auch, wenn es dann darum geht, ja, sollte man die Haare nicht anders tragen, muss man halt auch vorsichtig sein, was man Leuten für Vorschriften darüber macht, wie sie auszusehen haben oder wie sie ihre Körper zu gestalten haben. Weil, ja, das ist halt auch einfach ein Fakt. Da gibt es auch einen sehr, sehr guten Artikel oder Kommentar von Mara Pfeiffer, zu dem könnten wir uns auch mal verlinken vielleicht. Da fand ich, hat sie das sehr, sehr gut dargestellt, warum diese Diskussion halt auf vielen Ebenen dann auch problematisch sein kann, schnell.
Also man muss natürlich da schon aufpassen. Ich würde jetzt nicht den Ack, in einem Spiel jemanden an den Haaren zu ziehen. Das ist für mich nicht gleichbedeutend, wie eben das Rassistische. Darf ich mal dein Haar anfassen, ohne zu fragen, ohne Konzentration zu holen? Nein, überhaupt nicht. Ja, das kam in dem Kommentar nämlich so ein bisschen rüber, dass quasi auch das eigentliche Greifen schon was Rassistisches ist. Es hat eine rassistische Konentation, aber es ist ja in dem Kontext komplett anders. Es ist ja letztlich, ich wollte am Trikot ziehen, was auch nicht gut ist, ehrlicherweise. Also es wird immer so getan, als ob es völlig normal sein müsste, dass man hier mal am Trikot ziehen darf. Da könnte man ja auch mal drüber diskutieren. Aber ja, genau, das wollte ich nur kurz noch einordnend dazu sagen. Werde ich verlinken? Ja, Chris, Entschuldigung.
In der Premier League war das jetzt, also soweit ich es mitbekommen habe, war das jetzt gar kein Thema, ob und wie man seine Haare tragen sollte. Es ging vielmehr darum, dass Regie Le Brida meinte, das war keine Absicht, er wollte ihn gar nicht. Aber wenn man sich so die Videoaufnahmen ansieht, ist das schon, die Gegner wissen schon, was sie da tun in diesem Moment. Und ich finde es halt einfach ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, ein bisschen zu leicht, wenn man sagt, ja, wie soll ich ihn denn sonst verteidigen?
Das ist es halt. Und noch dazu, also wenn es wirklich so wäre, dass Spielerinnen mit langen Haaren nicht zu verteidigen sind, in einer Sportart, in der die gerade ihren Schlaf bis auf die Minute genau tracken und ihre Ernährung und so weiter, um noch die kleinen Marginal Gains rauszuholen, um dem Sieg näher zu kommen. Warum haben dann nicht alle so lange Haare? Also, ja, die Frage muss man doch stellen. Aber gut, das ist jetzt nochmal eine ganz andere Debatte. Ihr fünf, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Ihr habt euch viel Zeit genommen. Die Hörerinnen und Hörer haben es gemerkt. Wir sind in die Overtime gegangen. Daran bin allein ich schuld, weil ich gesagt habe, heute schnell durch und da mache ich eine riesen Champions League-Debatte auf. Daniel hat sich auch noch gemeldet. Hast du noch einen Gerichtsurteil, was du noch vergessen hast?
Nein, es gibt den Nachtrag aus der Bundeswasserkonferenz. Es ist der Pruder, wie ich hatte recht.
Danke, danke, danke.
Das ist der Wetter von toll.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Also ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Vielen, vielen Dank für eure Zeit.
Sehr gerne, bis bald.
Ich habe jetzt hier Nicken eingefangen. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Die Tür, bei Doc Mustache, bei Milbertshofen ist rot, bei SGD Thomas und bei Voller RWE. Sie alle haben uns nicht nur unterstützt, wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt, das erfahrt ihr in den Show Notes zu dieser Sendung oder wenn ihr auf rasenfunk.de geht und dort auf den Unterstützen-Button klickt. Und da haben sich nämlich diejenigen genannten gerade auch als Supportende registriert. Dann kann ich nach dem Zufallsprinzip euch hier rauspacken. Geht einfach auf rasenfunk.de, klickt auf den Unterstützen-Button. Da bekommt ihr alle Informationen, auch was wir mit eurem Geld eigentlich machen. In diesem Sinne, danke für euren Support. Feedback zu dieser Sendung sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und dann bleibt oder werdet gesund und bleibt uns gewogen. Bis bald wieder im Rasenfunk.
Ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.